peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec nous ce soir mais bon
jumbo
johan de moor
chantal goya
[Applaudissements]
m
bernard henri lévy
aya journal
justin
signé
non
j'en ai
fortement
et maintenant
[Musique]
j'accueille philippe de gaulle
non
oui
[Musique]
il
bonsoir amiral bonsoir monsieur
auditions alors ce qu'elle ait fait ça
vous fait d'être à la télévision est ce
que vous avez le trac quand vous venez à
la télévision oh moi j'ai pas de talent
ni de goût particulier pour la
télévision frais provenant de la marine
nationale nous pratiquions la discrétion
ouais mais mon père c'est différent il
avait appris votre père l'a appris d
avant guerre il avait d'abord compris
l'importance des médias
il l'a appliqué pendant la guerre bien
sûr l'appel du 18 juin pour commencer et
puis c'est un métier qui l'a appris
finalement au fur et à mesure des années
jusqu à le pratiquer avec une certaine
maîtrise
quand il est devenu président de la
république moi je me souviens en mai 68
quand il a fait son allocution à la à la
radio on était avec des amis étudiants
révolutionnaires dans un dans un parc
public et on l'a entendu à la radio il a
retourné tout le monde en un discours a
été très très fort en radio ah oui
d'autant que la télévision ne marchait
pas vrai voilà il n'avait que la radio
et la radio sur transistors alors pour
ceux qui voudraient pas reconnu philippe
de gaulle vous êtes le fils de charles
de gaulle ancien inspecteur général de
la marine depuis 1986 sénateur ump de
paris
alors évidemment c'est pas facile d'être
le fils du général de gaulle mais vous
avez accepté votre testa avec courage et
et modestie vous dit j'aurais pu naître
fils de pygmées ou de banc tout le sort
en a décidé autrement
on ne choisit pas sa place pour vous
votre place implique plus de plus de
devoirs que de droits d'une certaine
façon
non je dirais autant de devoirs que de
droits il faut pas diminuer ce qui
s'étripent temps de devoir goliat droit
oui tout à fait tout à fait ben oui mais
c'est ainsi il faut assumer
la place que le sort vous attribuez
ouais alors bien que fils du général de
gaulle vous n'avez jamais cédé à la
facilité à 20 ans vous choisissez
l'armée la marine
ensuite pendant la guerre vous sillonnez
la manche dans les vedettes lance
torpilles des forces françaises libres
donc une guerre très très courageuse
vous débarquez avec la 2e db et vous
participez à la meurtrière campagne
d'alsace donc tout le monde connaît
l'action de votre père pendant la guerre
mais on peut dire que vous aussi
philippe de gaulle vu une action très
très courageuse a oui je ne pouvais pas
être autrement qu'être en première ligne
y compris dans la deuxième division
blindée alors il ya eu deux mille livres
écrits sur le général de gaulle votre
père mais jamais le témoignage de
quelqu'un d'aussi proche son propre fils
vous êtes le dernier témoin privilégié
vivant vous dites après mois on fera du
roman vous êtes le dernier à pouvoir
certifier de ce qui s'écrit puisque ma
soeur aussi discrète que ma mère
garde le silence il n'y a donc plus
qu'un seul témoin et le moment est venu
pour moi de témoigner
après on écrira ce qu'on voudra mais en
moins en [ __ ] le plus d'éléments que
possible et en tout cas plus que ce
qu'on en a maintenant à en juger par ce
qu'on écrit parfois enfin
d'affabulations ou deux interprétations
abusives
combien de fois ai-je entendu dire que
mon père disait l'intendant suivre oui
c'est vrai mais il n'a jamais dit ça au
contraire pour lui la tendance précédait
toujours
alors donc à 81 ans vous parlez philippe
de gaulle dans un livre événement un
livre d'entretiens avec l'écrivain
journaliste michel tauriac qui s'appelle
de gaulle mon père qui est édité chez
plon
alors ce livre évidemment fourmille
d'informations historiques et et
d'éléments plus personnel à commencer
par la difficulté à s'appeler de gaulle
vous dit finalement que peut pas passer
une journée aujourd'hui sans entendre
parler du général de gaulle c'est vrai
on a ses propres parents disparus en soi
même on vit avec eux mais en plus je ne
peux pas passer un jour sans voir mon
nom écrit le nom de mon père pour une
question ou une autre alors en plus
comme vous lui ressemblez énormément
vous le savez vous pouvez pas aller dans
le métro puis pas le cinéma c'est très
difficile pour vous ça fait partie de
nos statuts ouais c'est ce qu'on doit
assumer c'est comme ça alors quand
avez-vous pris conscience du fait que
votre père n'était pas comme les autres
qu'il était différent voire supérieurs
aux tréteaux way très tôt je dirais 4 5
en 1
alors je sais que tous les petits
garçons se disent mon père est
formidable elle est toujours le mieux et
cetera mais tout de même je me suis
aperçu que le personnage central c'était
toujours lui même cantine disait rien et
d'ailleurs dans le louvre âge que je
publie envoie une photo du sous
lieutenant charles de gaulle au 33ème
régiment d'infanterie qui au bout de
table des jeunes à la pop est en
campagne avec les officiers de son
bataillon qui a des vieux capitaine ya
le commandant en chef de bataillon il ya
beaucoup de mais on ne voit qu'un seul
personnage c'est lui n'arrête en bout de
table
et pourtant s'il n'y a que lui qu'on
voit l'enfance assez difficile quand
même discipline assez ferme à la maison
est ce que votre père vous mettez des
débats sans fin les gifles non si vous
voulez me faire dire que nous avions une
éducation prussienne certainement pas un
débat fond n'en reçoivent est quand on
était petit d'ailleurs c'est comme ça
que la lionne réagi avec le lion un
réseau un où l'ours avec le petit il
faut le ramener dans le droit chemin et
que faire avec un petit qui met la main
dans la soupe
la ville de nantes après voilà son ca et
bien c'était les coutumes du milieu
auquel j'appartenais il fallait être
dans un moule et répondre quand on vous
adresser la parole
voilà à table les enfants par les pattes
encore à table les on pouvait parler pas
si j'entendais interrogé par il devient
vais rien réclamer votre chanson si on
les avait oubliés ou s'il n'y avait pas
de cuillères ou de in de nigériens ne
vais rien dire
votre mère avait quand même la main un
petit peu plus lourde que votre père ma
mère avait besoin de s'affirmer un peu
plus ouais mon père avait une autorité
naturelle sur el rey qu'il avait pas
besoin de s'imposer
votre mère était pas très maternelle à
ma mère était une mère parfaite
c'est à dire que ses enfants avaient
tout ce qu'elle pouvait leur donner
mais ne les mignardises ait pas de les
caresser pourrait ne les sauve quand il
était très petit vos parents philippe de
gaulle former un couple la discrétion
s'impose est celle que quand votre père
rentré à la maison
il embrassait votre mère sur les joues
sur le ferons jamais sur la bouche
devant vous ah non jamais jamais jamais
vu non une leur bras de fer et j'étais
considéré comme le comportement du
couple en public alors le père suivait
de près vos études
ils apprenaient des fables et des poèmes
par coeur pour vous les faire réciter
c'est insensé
il la prenait lui-même ce qui lui fut
utilisée trois fois le poème par mois là
et il faisait réagir et oui en ce
présent se raser pour m'indiquer comment
on devait le réciter alors vous dites je
devais être parmi les dix premiers de la
classe il fallait que je sois avant les
autres c'était obligatoire oui et disait
ça m'est égal que
tu es un demi point si les autres en 0
alors finalement vous rentrez dans la
dans la marine il sait jamais vraiment
mêlée de votre carrière ne l'a jamais
jamais beaucoup intervenu dans votre
carré militaire et finalement il a
failli vous oublié dans ses mémoires de
guerre et là il a oublié finalement vous
étiez comportés en héros pendant la
guerre héros non bah quand même et il
ajouté il a rajouté de sa main sur le
sont les manuscrits monfils continue à
se battre avec la 2e db
comment vous expliquez ça comment vous
expliquer que finalement il vous est
tellement mis de côté à ce moment là et
bien parce que il était en train
d'écrire ses mémoires de guerre mais il
ne raconte pas l'histoire de sa propre
famille à peine
ce boîtier saint-louis la discrétion et
puis je lui ai dit à la fin tout de même
vous pourriez dire que votre propre fils
a fait le tour de bout en bout et pas
l'arrière
il a dit oui c'est vrai mais je sais pas
pour raconter l'histoire de ma famille
alors il a rajouté monfils continue à se
battre
il s'agissait de la libération de paris
point final il aurait pu peut-être ça
aurait pu arriver
écrire mon fils a été tué il n'a pas été
le seul
ouais ouais vous en avez vous lu de voir
aussi peu de considération finalement
pour vos beaux faits d'armes pendant la
guerre non pas du tout ils le savaient
ils savaient très bien ça ne sert à rien
d'être le fils du général de gaulle
quand il faut affronter deux nuits sur
un porte-avions mais il faut accosté à
bateaux pourquoi il faut être fair
lentilles chars avec la première ligne
d'avant crise à faire absolument à rien
alors c'est pas la peine qu'ils
s'emmêlent a alors sur le plan
historique philippe de gaulle vous
apporter un éclairage évidemment sur le
mois de juin 40
le refus de paul reynaud le président du
conseil de quitter la france
il ya sa décision à lui de partir en
angleterre de se jeter à l'eau dit il et
de s'en remettre à dieu sert qu'à un
moment et c'est un geste qui est
fondateur pour tous pour tous qui suit
après c'est qu'à un moment il est entré
dans la rébellion il a franchi le
rubicon il savait pas où il allait il a
été tout seul contre tous
oui mais ne se considérait pas comme
rebelle il était secrétaire d'état d'un
gouvernement et il considérait que de la
troisième république et il considérait
que le reste étant sous l'influencé de
l'ennemi ne comptait pas voilà qu'elle
était toujours sous les lois de la
troisième république
il n'y avait pour lui aucun changement
de régime et il ne se considérait pas
comme rebelle il considérait que ce les
autres avaient failli mais lui continue
hessel devait continuer comme il le
disait parce que c'est l'honneur
les tous nos alliés continuent le combat
aux côtés des anglais y compris ceux qui
sont envahis comme les polonais les
hollandais et où il n'y a que nous qui
ne contient pas c'est l'intérêt
supérieur de la france parce que il faut
qu'elle fois victorieuse à la fin avec
tous les autres est ce le bon sens parce
que les allemands paieront alors souvent
se dit dans la vie d'aujourd'hui
soixante ans après on se dit qu'est ce
que j'aurais fait moi le 18 juin 40 est
ce que je serais parti à londres
est-ce que j'aurais accepté finalement
l'occupation ou le pétainisme
c'est une question qui est central
toujours aujourd'hui dans la dans la vie
des français c'est une question qu'on se
pose très souvent
oui mais il y avait beaucoup de jeunes
gens à l'époque qu'ils n'acceptaient pas
keane l'effondrement de la france que
pour eux ça paraissait incroyable
c'était d'ailleurs effectivement
incroyable ou bien le dire et aurait
voulu se battre ou continuer n'ont pas
pu parce qu'il se sent trouver très vite
bloqué alors vous et votre famille
philippe de gaulle embarquez donc à
brest sur un ratio propos l'angleterre
et quand vous arrivez à falmouth vous
savez pas vraiment où est votre père le
général de gaulle et c'est là vous voyez
dans le journal un entrefilet dix ans
qu'il a lancé un appel la veille donc en
est le 19 juin
oui il a été soumis à un rythme
absolument épuisant les dix derniers
jours du gouvernement français il
faisait l'aller retour de grande
bretagne france dans les 24 heures il
aller à tour et revenaient ils aller à
bordeaux il retournait à brest et par
conséquent il était fréquemment
grande-bretagne disons tous les 48
heures
ouais donc on savait que mon père
pouvait être en grande bretagne mais
nous n'étions pas sûrs de les retrouver
et nous avons traversé pour une autre
raison c'est comme j'avais une soeur
très infirme qui ne marchait pas et
qu'on ne pouvez pas déplacer en voiture
d'ailleurs n'avions pas de voitures
né en veut pas en train pas en quarts
alors ne pas nous laisser dépasser par
les allemands c'est la consigne que nous
avions partir du bretagne nord où nous
étions en vacances pour aller à nantes
ou à bordeaux avec cette fille infirme
ma mère a décidé que ce serait plus
simple par prendre un bateau pour aller
en grande bretagne ce qu'elle avait fait
en 1914 déjà une fois alors ensuite
philippe de gaulle vous commenter un
certain nombre d'événements historiques
de la deuxième guerre mondiale le
sabordage de la flotte à mers-el-kébir
laprise raté de dakar l'assassinât
darlan la dénonciation de jean moulin et
surtout l'affirmation du général de
gaulle à l'issue de la guerre pour
imposer la france comme un des
vainqueurs pour redonner dit-il le moral
à la nation après que le ressort était
cassé
puisque l'effondrement politique était
devenue totale
ouais mon père a considéré qu'il n'était
pas un commandant d'art de forces armées
et qu'il défendrait les intérêts du
peuple français
il a toujours fait valoir autant à
l'ennemi qu'à ses propres alliés que le
peuple français est incontournable et
qu'il fallait toujours compter avec lui
c'est ainsi qu'il a commencé à prendre
un rôle politique souvent d'ailleurs
inconfortable pour ses alliés fille de
gaulle cette idée de dire aux français
finalement la france s'est bien
comportée de leur faire croire un petit
peu qu'ils ont tous été résistant
pendant la guerre ça partait d'un bon
sentiment
pour redresser le moral de la nation
mais on sait bien qu historiquement
c'est faux tout de même
nous nous sommes effondrés en 1940 parce
que nous avons étions mal organisé nous
avions des préjugés militaire périmés et
nous étions mal comment des ouais car
nous étions dans une république était
déjà très jugé ouais donc les armées
étaient mal commandé mais tout de même
il faut pas oublier que en mai juin 40
les français ont eu c'est 116000 tuées
et 600 mille blessés
oui et quand nous étions tous seuls oui
mais quand même après après la guerre
quand votre père faisait les comptes
vous voyez le nombre de gens qui avaient
été dans la résistance sur chez pam
assure 40 ou 45 millions d'habitants à
l'époque ça faisait pas beaucoup quand
même
il y avait 40 millions 39 y avait
beaucoup d'attentes east c'est vrai mais
il y avait quand même une proportion de
résistants qui petit à petit mais a pu
attrait pertes auriez monte environ
40000 résistants patenté enregistrés
dans des réseaux une centaine de
milliers d'autres qui n'étaient pas dans
des réseaux mais qui les ont aidés et
qui ont risqué la capture ou même d'être
fusillé environ deux ou trois cent mille
autres qui les ont aidés ouais les le
peuple français c'est quand même résisté
à résister tout de même
oui il aura donné beaucoup d'importance
à se convertir alors bien sûr pour des
raisons politiques mais aussi morale
alors vous parlez aussi donc de
l'épuration son refus de gracier des
écrivains collaborationniste qui lui a
été beaucoup reproché notamment
brasillach laval fusillé alors qu'il
était dans le coma
parce qu'il ait fait une tentative de
suicide il a voulu se suicider en
absorbant un poison qui était
partiellement périmés mais il serait
mort de toute façon on aurait pu le
laisser mourir mais skalli votre père
soit la maison avec alex y aurait alors
le maréchal pétain votre père voulait
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient condamnés
évidemment en sachant qu'il allait le
grâcier qu'il ne laisserait pas fusillé
mais il disait
si moi j'étais tombé dans les mains de
vichy il aurait pas eu autant de
clémence avec moi incontestablement il
aurait tout de suite été fusil et
d'ailleurs et les allemands ne leur est
exigé
ouais oui ce qui fait qu'ils ont fait
deux procès successifs 1 ils ont d'abord
réduit au grade de colonel et allah et à
une amende
et puis sans doute les allemands at il
protesté et un mois pourraient ils ont
réuni un conseil de guerre qui à ce
moment-là l'a condamné à mort est la
confiscation de ses biens ray et à la
perte de sa nationalité
donc il le réfugié alors que lui n'a pas
fait fusiller péta y aura doute adieu
way
souvent quand on parle en france des
américains et de l'anti américanisme on
se réfère au général de gaulle et
j'attends une phrase dans votre livre
qui est finalement assez d'actualité
aujourd'hui
est-ce que
c'est ne pas aimer les américains de
considérer qu'ils n'ont pas à décider
pour la france dont chaque pays défendre
son peuple ses intérêts qui sont pas les
mêmes il faut rappeler ce que le papier
que les états unis remettait à chaque
soldat américain qui débarquait en
france et qui est qui était intitulé
vous n'êtes pas là pour libérer la
france mais pour combattre un ennemi des
états unis ouais ouais
même si vous libérer la france c'est pas
le but de fait tous les français même
ceux qui ont libéré les états unis en
1786 au temps des guerres d'amérique
sont morts en réalité pour la france
pour le roi qui le représentait à
l'époque comme les américains les
soldats américains qui ont été tués sont
morts pour les états unis d'amérique et
les français pour la france c'est tout
chacun a ses intérêts et sa personnalité
propre à défendre aussi il faut voir que
les journalistes souvent parce que ça
faisait de la copie exagérait les
différends qui pouvait y avoir même s'il
y avait des différences fondamentales y
en avait c'est bien bien sûr j'ai états
unis étaient à leur place et nous à la
nôtre est-ce que l'attitude de la france
face à la guerre d'irak vous semble dans
la ligne gaullienne de votre père au
très certainement certainement mon père
se serait d'abord demandé qu avons nous
affaire dans ce pays en étant donné que
nous ne pouvons rien réglé nous français
il s'agit de nous français il s'agit pas
les autres donc le gaullisme perdu lors
d'une certaine façon le golif perdure
alors y'en a qui voudrait qu'il ne
perdure pas durer il perdu en tous les
cas oui alors à l'époque où votre père
est parti pour londres évidemment
l'opinion publique était favorable à
pétain il a décidé lui d'incarner tout
seul la résistance face aux nazis
à votre avis aujourd'hui contre quoi
devons-nous résister contre la décadence
la peur contre la perte de confiance en
nous mêmes
mon père écrivait la france vient du
fond des âges
elle vit les siècles l'appel et quelle
que soit la situation
elles restent elles mêmes donc la france
qui tombe pour vous ça se corrige et
celles qui se laisse aller ouais
d'accord alors à l'époque de radio
londres on disait les français parlent
aux français
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que les français
devraient dire aux français a il faut
pas se laisser aller au déclin marotte
toujours gardé l'avenir n'est jamais
inéluctable
ouais les choses les choses ne sont pas
on ne peut pas savoir trois ans quatre
ans cinq ans après ce qui va se passer
les choses ne sont pas réglées davance
une fois pour toute c'est l'histoire et
il n'y a pas de sens de l'histoire ce
n'est pas vrai c'est une fausse théorie
qui était une doctrine mais une doctrine
très ancienne maintenant alors vous
n'êtes pas désespérer sérieusement
aujourd'hui de voir qu'en france y a pas
d'homme politique de l'envergure de la
stature de votre père tout le monde peut
pas être le général de gaulle c'est ce
que disait georges pompidou quand il lui
a succédé un jour m'invitant à dîner la
seule fois où il met invitait d'ailleurs
après mon père plusieurs années il m'a
dit qu'est ce que vous voulez je fais
comme je peux je ne suis pas le général
de gaulle d'un oui il n'est pas le
général de gaulle les chinois m'ont dit
un personnage comme votre père il y en a
un tous les siècles tous les deux
siècles dans chaque pays
alors on a beaucoup de parler de votre
père philippe de gaulle
j'aimerais avant nous séparer candidats
mot sur votre fils qui s'appelle charles
de gaulle qui est au front national
de gaulle et le pen sur la même affiche
ça vous fait quoi on monfils l'âge du
premier ministre mon grand père est mort
il ya trente trois ans et on n'accuse
pas d'autre chose d'autre
la faire et c'est à lui de voir son
affaire ça vous a désolé ça ne
m'entraînais pas sur ce sujet je vous
répondrai pas il est majeur et vacciné
merci merci d'avoir été agréé vous
ajouter quelque chose pour les plus
jeunes qui nous entende on représente
trop souvent le général de gaulle comme
un dinosaure way or personne ne sait
plus adaptée à son temps au temps qu'il
avait il a connu trois cultures trois
civilisations que le général de gaulle
et il faut que tous ceux qui sont ici
autour se souviennent que l'inventeur et
lé incitateur l'organisateur de la
sécurité sociale un des assedic c'est
lui vote des femmes le voit des femmes
est aussi le régime bilité de la même
façon que les hommes du texte et que
quand il monte dans un tgv c'est le
choix du général de gaulle il a choisi
le tgv contre le turbo train ou le train
un coussin d'air
le concorde celle général de gaulle
l'aer l'airbus qui s'appelait aéro bus
une supercar avait les caravelles celle
général de gaulle
le nucléaire c'est le général de gaulle
le périphérique autour de paris et les
autoroutes c'est le général de gaulle
alors voilà pour le passé en réalité le
général de gaulle était un dernier merci
beaucoup merci jégo
le volontaire entretien
il
bon
oh
qu'est-ce que je suis juste allée la
lâcher attendez je vais te présenter ça
va être super amiral je vous présente
jamais lu debout à présenter comme je
connais tous vos sens et remporte tous
les ronds projet this fait un pas qui
attend juste gérer alors qu'elle coûte
monde qu'est ce qu'il fait là
ouais comme je sais que tu as beaucoup
de boulot hein tu travailles comme un
fort c'est vrai j'ai préparé la venue ce
que j'ai lu c'est très intéressant long
à lire on prend son temps
oui il faut prendre son temps évidemment
c'est parce que j'aurai comme j'ai pas
le temps moi c'est pour ça que je laisse
tirer lire il me racontait hier les
regarde tout le monde en parle pour
savoir ce qui attend les lézatois etc
très bien organisée
en tout cas observés pour radio
longtemps j'ai kiffé encore aussi je
vous ai déjà dit et l'appel du 18 juin
comme je suis né le 18 juin ça me fait
kiffer ses partisans à travers sa
personne
rien à dire jacques actuelle enregistre
un théâtre quand est ce que moi
moi je te je décris les questions pour
pas que tu perds ton temps tu m'as fait
des questions quant au parrain évite de
me poser des questions la cour du style
tromper csu c'est black pepper je me
mélange fait comme si j'étais pas au
courant des questions
bon vous restait cinq minutes avec nous
bah je vous remercie japon djamel qu'est
ce que vous faites là
nantes un jeu mais avant chanel n'ont
jamais battu respire jamais benjamin a
oui je savais que c'était benjam elle
bonsoir mon sang en syrie après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui l'un des acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
djamel si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est
ce que ça vous fait aujourd'hui à moins
de 30 ans de vous retrouver au panthéon
des acteurs français
[Applaudissements]
ouais le panthéon c'est la fin mais on
lui
là encore 30 ans il a beaucoup de choses
à faire l'achat alors jamais c'est
vraiment un honneur et un immense
privilège d'avoir l'honneur de vous
avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui l'un des acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est ce que
ça fait aujourd'hui de vous retrouver au
panthéon des acteurs français
je sais pas si on peut dire ça comme ça
ouais je sais pas si risqué panthéon ou
arc de triomphe pour réfléchir rien à
foot c'est plus difficile c'est pas moi
aussi les jaunes c'est les autres qui
vont au moins une certaine navailles
extraordinaire moi je subis plus tu vois
si je suis pas trop gros je fais je fais
des choses naturellement passé c'est le
style c'est le style c'est clair
pourtant djamel d'après le journal de
mickey vous êtes l'acteur préféré les
enfants je tiens à remercier les enfants
en particulier pour pour ça c'est vrai
et ça s'est joué
ça s'est joué à ça entre mois plus tôt
et c'est vrai qu'entre un chien de
débiles et un arabe qu'à la classe et
autres sur canal jamel c'est quoi vos
plus grandes qualités à part bien sûr la
bogossité la générosité la même minute
et ça et iris est très difficile de
parler de soi
ouais j'ai envie de dire là la modestie
oui oui modestie c'est bien aussi si ça
fait 2-1 dans le genre modeste laisse
très modeste six filles de vaud l'a
alors est ce qu'il vend des livres c'est
incroyable il pour vingt mille livres
par jour j'avais fait une énorme lui en
vendre 500 milles la rigole c'est
d'abord les premières à son effigie et
d'éviter comme des aéroports de métro
voici mois ci ses amis ouais c'est ça
que voir quel beau si un jour il ya
rigal airport s'appelle le jamel
debbouze comment je kifferais stephen j
[Applaudissements]
et j imagine si philippe de gaulle
premier du pognon sur charles de gaulle
roissy charles de gaulle étoile station
charles de gaulle il faut ils pourraient
s'acheter pas de cravate bordeaux
jamel est ce que tant qu'il est là
est ce que tu es ce que tu as une
question à lui poser philippe de gaulle
vous êtes donc le fils forcément de
charles est ce que il aimer le rap est
ce qu'ils connaissaient tupac shakur ou
biggie smalls par exemple de son temps
comme ça il lui arrivait de danse et de
partir en vrille on part en chêne on est
regardé les gens danser mais jamais
jamais voulait prendre pris en flag dans
votre salon j'allais le singe est épuisé
il était très strict
la carte postale non c'est pas ça mais
comme ce n'était pas dans son talent il
préférait regarder ceux dont le talent
mais parce qu'on voit les chefs d'état
en paix
de mon point de vue en tout cas que je
suis pas chef d'état de mon état je me
dis que y
ils sont toujours obligés tout le temps
toute leur vie d'être sérieux oui sans
doute sérieux mais ça les empêche pas de
s'amuser par trois mais c'est un jeu
serré a dit non quand même s'ils sont
pas un sourire et qu'on les voit pas
rire ya des choses qui les amuse il n'a
jamais une touche d'expérience des
frères temps il et il était plutôt
gentil plus tôt et tous âges plutôt
chefs d'état le les gentilles et et
chats ils avaient affaire a beaucoup de
difficultés et forcément ils n'avaient
pas que sa fermeture et par on l'avait
fait venir pour sa menace était un peu
aller le chercher pour aller le chercher
dans tout
ça fait comme on dit chez moi merci
beaucoup merci ville et de vol
et maintenant l'effort du enit ans y est
bientôt vance
de fermer
si jean jacques debout
[Musique]
aussi
genou
jean-jacques ça va bonjour thierry tu as
vu je me suis fait faire une coupe
bannières comme ça t'es pas dépaysés ça
va parce que vous savez que jean jacques
debout et là messieurs à passer l'été au
frais 1
c'est le cas de le dire comment ça va la
santé va mieux mais au début de la
canicule jeu mardi avec comment ça va
fleurir
[Rires]
comment ça va la santé est là ça va ça
oui ça va je m'ennuie de mes camarades
bah ouais c'est normal car vos camarades
de me taire justement jean jacques
ils étaient impressionnés que vous ayez
composé booba le petit ourson sûrement
en leur avais dit en arrivant c'est moi
qui ai fait booba le petit ourson donc
d'un seul coup respect à celui qui vole
tombe il a chanté un coup oui c'est vrai
jusqu'à 5 heures du matin donc début
juillet jean-jacques vous rentrez chez
vous bourrez accident sans gravité un
celui-là le premier la boulevard rené
coty pas de problème pitt accident sympa
quoi jacques accrochage l'accident de
quartier ouais le petit accrochage tout
seul l'accrochage quand même voilà oui
pas de permis pendant six mois mais
enfin bon après tout un bon une semaine
plus tard
or là c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
contrôle au volant vous conduisait la
voiture de chantal goya avec 1,84 gramme
d'alcool dans le sang et par personne et
c'était cela
ben alors attendez il a payé sa peine à
la société donc franchement je veux dire
l'agent ja que ce soit est parfaitement
réhabiliter on parle de ça parce que
évidemment c'est amusant et là tu ouvre
une boîte contenant la 4g toujours j'ai
toujours dit que j'avais fait une
connerie j'ai jamais dit que c'était de
la faute de la police
j'ai fait une connerie je lave où je me
suis pris plein la gueule
voilà c'est bien fait pour moi voilà
alors ce qui s'est passé jean-jacques en
fait c'est que vous vouliez aller une
émission de radio j'ai demandé un taxi
m'a dit moi je peux pas parce que je
serai pas chez vous pendant deux heures
mais enfin toujours est il que vous avez
pris la voiture de chantal or le fameux
soulier qui vole et là c'était une
émission où il y avait des gens qui
m'appelaient sur l'antenne
je me suis dit bon c'est plus je peux
pas faire autrement j'étais enclavé au
parc montsouris
je sais que vous habitez oui alors ce
qui s'est passé effectivement c'est
qu'après l'émission de radio jean
jacques
il va dans une brasserie et il tombe
sous intermittents du spectacle il
discute évidemment nuit j'ai quand même
discuté m'ont appelé m'ont demandé de
venir boire un verre à l'arc
ils discutent ils discutent ils discuter
discuter discuter scutella pas gouré
joseph c'était le début où il commence à
faire très chaud hein et puis c'est y
servait du côtes-du-rhône ferait un élan
quand on quand on commence avec ça on a
l'impression de boire de l'eau quoi mais
c'est un problème qu'on leur a dit
donner au personnage est bas alors
ensuite ce qui est terrible c'est que
ils vous ont amené jean jacques dans la
cellule de dégrisement sortant la
cellule dégrisement ça va encore un bon
c'est pas terrible mais ça va mais là où
ça devient difficile c'est que le
lendemain vous êtes déféré au parquet et
là on vous amène dans la souricière ans
la souris sien c'est terrible passé un
jour et une nuit en attendant d'être
jugées dans cette souricière
ces salles il ya des sourires à cause
des rats c'est épouvantable parce que
c'est d'abord on est trois dans une dans
une cellule qui fait trois mètres sur 2
et puis bon bah
il ya des pauvres gars qui sont
incarcérés sa tournée les uns sur les
autres
envie d'aller aux toilettes il n'y a pas
de papiers alors bon bah il s'essuie
après les murs à puis après il ya les
blattes les rabais et puis elles montent
jusqu'au plafond au plafond elles
perdent l'équilibré parce qu'elles
savent plus où aller
delirium tremens cl je tombe sur la
gueule mais elle tombe sur laquelle vous
voyez des rats géants avec des iguanes
qui rend claire
voilà en pleine descente
que dire des choses bien enfin dans tous
les cas il ya un mec qui veut vous
piquer votre montre à ce moment là jean
jacques debout dans la souricière est
heureusement il ya un africain qui est
là et qui dit tu le touches pas ses
chansons ont bercé mon enfance vrai coup
de bol oui ça est impliqué dans le
lendemain vous êtes condamné à un an de
prison dont trois mois ferme c'est pas
de la rigolade trois mois ferme pour
trois raisons la première c'est 1,84
gramme d'alcool dans le sang
je sais pas exactement ce que ça fait
mais apparemment c'est beaucoup pas de
permis et la cyber me retirer pour 24
mois et les 6/10 jeu systématiquement
pour oublier
ensuite jean jacques debout et emmenés à
la prison de la santé là vous arrivé
vers 22 heures
on vous donne des draps sympa un des
draps des taies d'oreiller m'attend ce
bruit enfin oui sympa matos pour la
toilette et où quand même non oui c'est
comme les vallons lillois enfin oui
chiant dur le premier soir oui c'est
assez dur parce que déjà n'y a pas de
room service
et puis bon il y avait un prisonnier qui
s'appelle patrice qui est très très
gentil qui est un peu l'intendant de du
quartier ou un quartier vip il faut bien
le dire comme dans un vieux hippies
c'est parce qu'on est tout seul par
cellule c'est sûr pas max c'est ça
irrite c'est là que ça qui vient hippie
et puis là jean jacques debout il se met
à penser à mesrine parce que ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que jean jacques était
au collège de julie avec mesrine un
voisin qui a réussi comme celui-là en 47
1 et j'étais dans la même classe que
claude brasseur
c'est fou et alors quand il était à la
santé mesrine voulu écriviez à
j'écrivais oui régulièrement parce qu'il
me demandait toujours de lui envoyer de
lui faire envoyer des autographes de
michel drucker un 2d de tous les gens
qui regardaient dans sa cellule à la
révision
ce qui est dur quand même ces six heures
du soir là quand il ferme les cantines
fermées vers 6h30 oui quand il ferme les
verrous et là on peut plus parler à
personne
et puis bon bailleresse que la télé
puisque est terrible c'est que la nuit
il ya tous les prisonniers qui se
parlent d' parce qu'il ya plusieurs
bâtiments
et puis ils se parlent de bâtiments à
bâtiment parce qu'ils se retrouvent qui
sont perdus de vue pendant 15 ans il
sait pas le bâtiment en bâtiment des
rangs disant tu vois il parle de nous
quoi puisque ben oui ils temps en temps
il chanter mes chansons comme ça c'est
la fin pour finalement assez déprimée
cassine c'est ma cousine
en arabe un arabe benkaci n'en n'a que
terrible ce qui est terrible c'est que
donc à 6h30 on ferme les verrous et puis
pendant la nuit qui est là comme ça ils
temps en temps il allume évidemment ils
foutent un phare dans la gueule pour
voir que patrick warin toutes les airs
tout les airs c'est comme dans un stalag
il ya un phare énorme qui vous réveille
comme ça puis puis alors ils regardent
par le judas il referme pour voir si
rien est anormal ils font ça pour savoir
si le prisonnier pas en train de scier
les barreaux
alors finalement donc ça durera pas
trois mois ça durera que trois semaines
vous êtes autorisé jean jacques debout à
purger votre peine chez vous ce qu'on
appelle sous surveillance électronique
ce qu'on vous a mis un bracelet à la
suie agir et le bracelet est donc relié
à la balise balises reliées à la santé
ils ont un écran de télévision petit
écran 1
et quand ils veulent ils savent
exactement vous êtes un
normalement il fallait que je sois
rentré à 8h pini un jour j'étais pris
dans un encombrement et je suis arrivé à
8h02 vraiment et le le téléphone sonnait
déjà il avait préparé une voiture pour
venir me chercher
ah ouais et le jour où tu es attendu à
taxi pendant deux heures seraient les
appelait alors peu de gens savent qu
avant d'inventer le music hall pour
enfants avec chantal goya
vous avez commencé au théâtre à l'âge de
17 ans vous avez été ami avec
marie-laure de noailles dans le dernier
salon littéraire que comptait paris vous
avez connu eluard kessel vous
raccompagner cocteau chez lui sur sa
sueur marée soit basse et il me disait
c'est formidable votre motocyclette
j'adore faire de la moto 600 casques
suis un monsieur cocteau c'est une vesse
passée à huy sommes enfin et vous avez
connu marine des triches grande amitié
que même des tricheries parce que j'ai
fait sa première partie à l'olympia en
ouais et puis on est devenus très amis
j'ai écrit des chansons et puis on
emmenait faire le tour du monde avec
elle
dans tous les cas là où elle chantait il
ya la vie debout avant goya les gens la
connaissent pas mais c'est énorme et
composé pour johnny hallyday pour sylvie
pour christophe pour barbara vivent
montant pour marie laforêt pour presque
tous si vous aviez pas rencontré chantal
goya vous seriez devenue un immense
songwriter non didier pour moi la vie va
commencer
et mon passé
fort de leveau
voulant le st
chevauchant avec mais les amis pour moi
la vie va comment
excusez moi
monsieur
les seuls
[Musique]
si je ne connais
le son
[Musique]
je tiens debout
com
sans les cheveux longs comme un garçon
jeu portable ou un médaillon un costume
corps
le cpq est bien souvent le distribuer
des corrections vous faire attention
comme un des flancs
com
alexis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a
do
aussi loin
[Musique]
à
en casquette à galons dorés en cas
première du salon
dès jeudi en quarts
voyez passer les
cela
[Musique]
est ce là ta vie
les enfants
[Musique]
combien
jean jacques deleau jean jacques debout
un composé non seulement les détectives
ont d'autres chanteurs et pour vous
aussi alors vous en tant que chanteur
vous aviez du mal jean-jacques à à
chanter en dehors des petits comités
vous décapent a dit dédé qui a trop de
monde ça va pas un bas c'est à dire j'ai
fait deux fois l'olympia on va être dans
les années soit 72 4 c'est vrai
jean-jacques déjà en 66 je me suis un
gala du midem ou dans l'énervement vous
avez carrément déchiré toutes les
partitions de leurs gains
ça c'était géant 66 ouais en 76 au
palais des congrès vous arrêtez
pratiquement de chanter au milieu du
concert dire que vous vous sentiez pas
bien comme chanteur qua non je me
sentais pas comment on peut dire je me
demande un peu ce que je faisais là
hier donc à la même époque grâce à dieu
vous rencontrer chantal goya se dire
c'était l'anniversaire du fils de doc
d'albert ii basque depuis un moment on
m'a demandé de chanter j'ai chanté donc
les boutons dorés main et pendant que je
chantais dans la salle en finlande dans
le salon j'ai aperçu une petite brune
avec une petite robe rouge et puis et
puis je sais pas elle n'a plus et puis
j'ai été la voir et puis je lui ai dit
écoutez je crois qu'on se mariera vous
serez célèbre à 30 ans et vous chanterez
un jour à l'opéra de paris
alors elle m'a dit qu'on se marie ça
peut arriver que soient célèbres à 30
ans ça peut arriver mais quand tu as
chanté à l'opéra de paris je crois vous
fichez un peu de moins
j'accueille maintenant chantal goya
bonsoir il aime beaucoup chantal plus
envie de baiser chantal pour l'instant
lyn thériault deux là c'est le travail
d'avants après on va se détendre bordé
oui bien sûr notre ami narrateur la
sérieux surtout que chantal la double
promo ajouté bonsoir ou pas les
astreintes groupe mais triple promo oui
mais j'en connais deux mois il ya des
gens qui font un double album
moi j'ai le livre qui s'appelle la
niaque est une autobiographie
et puis le cd et le dvd et le palais des
congrès annuel à lui entendu bah oui
bien sûr mais oui c'est sûr ils n'ont
dit qu'on faisait écho liste
le cdh et le cd chez un best-of ses
dessins des stocks est égale à celle de
l'irak dominique afin d'en tirer clame
alors j'en ai
il peut deviner ce qu'il a envie de
manger bio c'est super pour moi c'est du
poisson ce qui réclame comme moi y est
fermé alors le cd donc c'est un best-of
et le dvd
c'est le spectacle mystérieux voyage de
marie rose
alors on va on va commencer par le
best-of voilà vous voulez écouter les
chansons de chantal goya didier
[Musique]
tél
je fais
non
m
alors c'est quoi la rassurer
ouah
oh
c
ouais
et
m
je pense que
de là
et
[Musique]
l'appui
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
allez
m
audard
d
ouais
et
[Musique]
il est
ça
chantal goya
le destin
[Applaudissements]
on se croirait au queen's ouais alors
dans cette optique au frais qu'est ce
qui alors on me dit qu'il faut tout
refaire
non on me dit qu'il faut tout refaire
chantal goya bonsoir il ya une caméra
sur alain chabat si vous pouvez me fit
d'agacer joffre ça ne règle ses affaires
à ta famille parce que bien sûr parfois
tu déconne mais parfois ça et pourtant
c'est à bellignat bien très très bien et
on va le faire même accéléré didier
c'est à longchamp
on n'est pas
m
il y a
ce qu'ils ont fait
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
bien alors maintenant on passe aux tv
game mystérieux voyage de marie rose
c'est quoi le pitch c'est un petit
garçon qui est une histoire vraie qui
est arrivé quand il était pensionnaire
qui était tombé dans une dans un lac
glacé et évidemment ce petit garçon d'un
mois je suis celle qui va le retrouver
et je me bats contre les quatre éléments
du monde à terre le feu l'eau et l'air
avec des enfants alors la terre on va
sous la terre on recompte des rétro que
pour toi mais qui va t'y faire gel des
zoulous ses 10 ans et plus dans le
royaume des pâquerettes
c'est bisounours j'arrive dans les bras
d'un dragon bleu qui me porte dans l'air
qui m'a même sous la neige les grog
tu voudrais encore des charmes et on se
dit ça c'est les années canal 84 ans
pile alors de votre caméra chantal
première
magnéto sur magnéto serge serge il est
chiant il veut vous le fassiez que les
oreilles de lapin comportant les petits
bouts demande comment on fait des
enfants vous répondez quoi schaller
l'habite
non mais le sait chantal si un petit nom
c'est un petit de 8 ans vous demande
comment on fait des enfants vous dit pas
avec la [ __ ] j'imagine dans un chou avec
la ville mais dans un show avait pour
but en bien vous dites quoi chanter vous
êtes plus que les balles jeudi que tu
vas voir tu toi tu as tu aimes tu es un
petit fiancée que tu adores et puis
c'est compliqué ce que vous me demandez
là bas non sans talent alors non
croyants ils ont des parents c'est leurs
parents qui n'auraient ce nom mais les
parents son attitude sur leur boulot de
parents vous savez bien ils ont tous
démissionné les parents depuis les 60
naturellement avec une perte ou une
partie de notre corps la calquer un
voilà voilà voilà tout simplement écrit
c'est très agréable qui ça se passe très
bien voilà football en ce sens pas bien
et alors qu'en mettant un petit enfant
vous dis maman pourquoi je vous dis pour
roger le gîte ou dur vous dites quoi
maintenant vous
est-ce que bécassine même lapine c'est
la question que beaucoup de gens se
posent chez eux
vraiment c'est tellement la question
non bien alors ça donc c'était le dvd le
cd laurent maintenant on va passer au
livre s'appelle la niaque 1 chez jacques
marie laffont éditeur
alors là on comprend mieux le personnage
de chantal goya votre côté un peu
enfants attardés
parce que finalement enlève enfants on
attendait son canon alors chantage je
vais vous dire laissez moi finir parce
qu'après il y avait après il y avait une
explication ce n'est pas juste non mais
la syrie je te rappelle que chantal a
peur elle a le trac il faut l'aider mais
oui mais s'ils n'étaient pas tu écoute
bien écoute bizou à l'origine des
fausses bel et bien battu mais la
pression
conserver
[Applaudissements]
non
parce qu'en même temps il n'y a pas de
postures le tuer tout ce que comprend
mieux le personnage de chantal goya un
peu enfants attardés
quand on sait que vous avez eu une prime
enfance en indochine à l'époque
coloniale c'est ce qu'on apprend en
lisant le livre et que vous avez gardé
de cette époque des souvenirs magiques
période très heureuse près de saigon les
vacances dans les montagnes à dalat au
cambodge etc
donc voilà ce que je voulais dire le
père le père de chantal diriger une
plantation d'hévéa de quarante mille
hectares il a été obligé de fuir le pays
ça a été l'épisode vous êtes retrouvés à
en métropole après un voyage
épouvantable et là vous vous retrouvez à
paris dans un minuscule appartement de
500 avec des grands-parents
insupportable voilà et vous recréez
votre enfance en indochine voilà ce que
je voulais dire c'est à dire que voilà
voilà
c'est vrai vous avez toute votre vie et
cherchait à retrouver cette prime
enfance indochinois est vraiment avec
avec les pousse-pousse avec les grands
arbres dire enfin la doshisha vais
j'avais une chinoise qui s'occupait de
moi qui tu n'as samax et une femme
sacrée qui a dû me donner quelque chose
d'important parce que mes frères et
soeurs on non pas un petit peu cette
espèce de tenues ce que j'ai et je
traverse toutes les difficultés toujours
avec optimisme la niaque la niaque
mais c'est vrai que déjà tout petit j'ai
traversé des difficultés sans même me
rendre compte par exemple quand il y
avait les japonais qui étaient au pied
de la maison et qu'ils voulaient
assassiner qui ont assassiné beaucoup de
français moi j'étais caché dans un dans
un sou ali je crois oui mon frère était
dans un placard et moi évidemment quand
maman regarder à travers les volets ce
qui se passait parce que les
vietnamiennes nous avait beaucoup et
nous et des mois j'ai traversé les la
maison j'ai descendu l'escalier j'ai
demandé à l'armée de là c'est mon lacet
de chaussure
voilà alors ils ont bas et son bep
saison là c'est mon lacet de chaussure
et puis son parti la famille était sauvé
voilà alors deuxième choc de votre vie
votre rencontre avec les beatles
les pirates avaient quoi allez pas vous
sortez avec le fils du duc et la
duchesse de bedford inculpé
lil wayne vous aviez même pas du diocèse
de belfort
non parce que nous on aller dans des
soirées origine soit à paris l'après
midi c'était soirée de l'après-midi moi
je sais on posait pas de question qu'est
ce que fait ton père ta mère et quand
j'étais à londres et que j'étais au père
gilles mali je t'emmènerai chez mes
parents en week-end ou en vacances ou
déjà mais je ne sais plus déjeuner alors
il est venu me suis rhabillé imposant
des to et tablier et autres et puis je
savais pas où j'étais tombé je n'en
croyais pas mes yeux est immonde il a
déjeuné y aura des gens importants qui
viendront et dans la grande salle à la
chaleur jacques tati au nom je lui dis
une fois pour toutes la retraite avec
les frères salah est moche et le coupon
mentale système association des stars
les frères jeannet mois ils sont vivants
et si tu le sais je le coupon mensuel à
tort tu aimes faire ça si mes
personnages je sais que c'est couper au
montage sur ces deux matches d'affilée
s'élève donc j'ai bon espoir
je le coupe aussi c'est vrai mater
altérée colette renard a non pas de
pascal sevran le marteau sur les réveils
avaient donc ces quatre personnages qui
sont arrivés et là j'ai halluciné
c'était les buts avaient tous les jeunes
et voilà c'était plus impressionné que
riri fifi et loulou il était co 3 3
contre chanter à l'époque que she loves
you s'est depuis la mi juillet y est
enfin c'était c'était à 8 mois pour moi
je et alors le choc suivant ça a été
votre rencontre avec jean jacques debout
là ça a été la va te faire ça y est
c'est à dire que à peine il vous a vus
il vous dit j'ai l'impression de vous
connaître depuis toujours on se mariera
on aura deux enfants vous serez célèbre
à 30 ans et vous chanterez à l'opéra en
attendant on va baiser la rage
c'est incroyable alors je lui ai dit bon
je veux bien là on se mariera peut-être
chanter certainement pas parce qu'il ya
je suis j'ai pas vraiment une voix d'un
alors quand à l'opéra si j'étais maria
callas ça serait et avoir deux enfants
bon c'est peut être possible
et ben voilà il est tout ce qui est
arrivé est arrivé quand même il vous
propose de le suivre antilles parce
qu'il allait participer à la rose d'or
avec ses géniales chanson qui s'appelle
audois se sont croisés et ils vous
oubliez à paris vous aux régions et
méfier un mec qui vous fait ça c'est un
mec vous le rencontrez et vous promet de
vous épousez de faire deux enfants ils
vous invitent à antibes et par sens vous
sur l'a10 vous servir de leçon je dois
vous ayez persévérer au delà de ça c'est
moi c'est moi c'est nous intéresse quant
au blé un mois quand elle me dit ça
c'est qu'il a vraiment quelque chose qui
m'intéresse c'est que je peux aller plus
loin ah bon et s'il me dit d'aller bien
ça y est c'est fait oublier à paris ça
vous a pas servi dans sa laïcité
gratitude on est obligé d'y aller avec
quelqu'un d'autre finale mais comme je
suis non parce que je me dis vous avez
fait un gros mensonge à mes parents je
leur avais dit que je partais un week
end chez une copine donc mon père m'a
dit je reconnais ce que tu as dans ton
sac alors j'ai montré à jean tennis et
après je peux plus rentrer parce que
j'avais non je pouvais pas j'ai dit il
faut que j'y aille et puis je tenais et
la gagner alors il avait arraché le
chèque au maire y avait un chèque de dix
mille francs et qu'est ce qu'il a fait
la maison il fait toujours ça ben voilà
avec des militants une fois il a acheté
un bateau avec un chèque de 200 francs
il avait rajouté 3 0 c'est vrai ou pas
la maison chaque fois je tourne les sens
pas quoi ils allaient au salon nautique
bon je peux même pas attention moi je
reviens ce soir à jean minuit et je vois
dans mon salon tabarly et petitpas r il
petit pas bons ils étaient tous là
autour des grandes et enfin d'un énorme
plan de bateaux jeudi qu'il souhaitait
que tout ça il ya ba oui j'étais
annoncer une bonne nouvelle ça y est
j'ai acheté un très beau bateau les
stein qui est qui avait été construit
par john alden jeudi mais comme on va
faire il dit bah oui non mais on
s'arrangera et où aulas j'ai appelé les
ateliers de la trinité s'était pas là
j'ai appelé tous les chantiers de
de rolande et c'était là et là j'étais
prendre un très gentil chercher mon
chèque et puis le bateau chaque 3 0 donc
à 19 ans vous installer avec lui et au
bout d'un moment vous avez envie de
faire du journalisme vous allez voir
daniel filipacchi en disant je veux
travailler dans la presse et lui vous
propose de chanter des chansons de jean
jacques debout et qu'est ce que je
chante c'est bien bernard le plus
veinard de la vie sur salut les copains
et puis voilà voilà j'étais affolée et
là alors pire que tout vous tourné avec
jean luc godard qui vous demande de vous
déshabiller c'est pour masculin féminin
et vous refusez de vous mettre toute nue
oui pourquoi vous avez bas d'abord
j'étais enceinte de mon fils et je
voulais pas le dire
bon ça commençait bien et on n'était pas
marié ouais j'ai su vraiment l'egypte
est enceinte de trois mois et j'ai dit à
marlène comment je peux faire marlène
jobert comment je peux faire je veux pas
d'abord je veux pas me [ __ ] à poil
samat je veux pas elle mais j'étais
inquiète pas tu vas te cacher sous le
lavabo et moi je vais passer une fois et
de fage fait passer en vente ont des
gestes à toi et moi je passais à ma
façon j'étais ok moi je t'ai planqué
sous lavabo pis godard a dit mais c'est
bizarre on dirait la même silhouette qui
basse il a ouvert la porte il m'a dit
mais dis donc tu te fiches de moi qu'est
ce que tu fais là dessous je dis bah moi
je vais pas tourner à poil alors je lui
dit tu seras jamais une vedette jeudi je
m'en fous la seule vedette que je
connais c'est ma machine à laver alors
du coup je bave des prix
[Applaudissements]
mais voilà alors après bombay c'est
l'époque des succès vous inventez avec
jean jacques debout le music hall pour
enfants c'est vous qui avez inventé ça
oui à tout ça sera coupée au montage à
kanata baiser pour la première fois
alors le vendredi 13 décembre 1985
ça porte malheur déjà patrick sabatier
vous reçoit dans le jeu de la vérité
vous appellerez cette émission un
meurtre en direct
oui et ce n'est que huit ans plus tard
que vous pouvez regarder la cassette de
l'émission et vous dites j'ai vu une
folle qui parle à moi d'abord j'avais
j'avais pas voulu la faire ce que
j'étais en plein spectacle mystérieux
voyage la marée rose que vous avez vu et
moi j'avais dit ça sert à rien parce que
c'est tellement archi complet je me vois
pas dans une émission où des adultes
vont parler donc ils m'ont dit non ce
sont des enfants qui vont venir vous
parler un à ce moment là j'ai douté un
peu et jean jacques m'a dit il n'en est
même pas question thierry le luron qui
était l'âme a dit chantal ils vont te
alors te planter ça va être l'horreur et
j'ai dit ok jaffe plus donc j'ai appelé
gilles on la fait plus et l'avant veille
le réalisateur m'a dit écoute au nom de
notre amitié tu devrais quand même la
faire ce sera magnifique aura des belles
choses on va voir jean jacques ne voyait
pas jean jacques qui ne veut pas
finalement tout on a tellement c'est moi
qui aie qui suis allé au charbon en fin
de compte
alors j'ai joué mon spectacle et la
veille jean jacques m'a dit tu vois
c'est bien là toute ligne de journaux
mais je peux te dire qu à 21h40 il y
aura plus de chantal goya
oui tu va au casse-pipe tu vas au casse
pipe et je me sente avec ma robe rose de
marée rose devant un dans mon décor avec
l'arbre la forêt et tout ayant joué
l'après-midi à 8h30 le même public
devant moi de 12000 personnes et pas une
question d'enfants et moi chaque fois
j'étais je prenais tout au troisième
degré alors quand est-ce que par celle
passée la chirurgie à la chirurgie
esthétique avec votre tronche donc c'est
pas grave on verra jour et puis toute
manière ce qui s'est passé chanteur
hélas oui voilà ce qui s'est passé c'est
que c'est qu'en fait vous croyez vous
adresser aux enfants et jeunes en
faisant des grimaces en disant je vais
mettre les enfants dans ma poche
non tu leur faire des grimaces et le
réalisateur rémy grand bac lui il montre
pas les je raconte ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'ils ont eu l'idée de mettre une
fausse institutrice 1
c'est elle qui a tout déclenché c'est
pas avant avant je m'en sortais très
bien ça c'est bien
et cette fausse institutrice quand je
vais demander de quelle classe vous êtes
elle n'a jamais pu me le dire c'était
eux gibbons alors à les fossés les
billets c'est finish dans un traquenard
alors là maintenant j'ai dit à sa bête
j'ai dit à cette femme bah écoutez vous
m'aimez pas changer de chaîne j'allais
pas dire madame vous êtes je suis une
conne et je vous remercie
moi c'est pas possible devant plus tout
mon public puis j'aime pas dire ça a
besoin n'est même pas question alors
j'ai dit bon ben je pose mon micro j'ai
dit à patrick moi juste désolé il ya
simone signoret sur l'a2 c'est beaucoup
mieux chantal goya je m'adresse à mon
public ils sont les enfants et je
chantais lapin et là j'ai posé mon micro
g il y avait tous ces gosses devant moi
qu'on ne montrait jamais voilà et les tv
ce marché lui l'a cru que sterbik vous
fait évidemment parce que dans la
panique ginestet d' attaques de panique
de terroriser et je me suis réfugié dans
le monde de l'enfance parce que j'étais
marie-rose way et l'image a été échangé
et moi j'ai vu quand je suis sorti de là
j'ai toujours pas compris à la fin
d'émission parce que tout le monde était
dans la salle a crié chantal chantal et
quand je suis sorti que j'ai vu là la
haie d'honneur de tous mes techniciens
qui était pratiquement en larmes
vous êtes arrivé dans la régie et là
vous vous tombez sur jean jacques debout
ivre mort jean-jacques il avait tout
compris et jean-jacques il vivait mal
tout ça il avait il avait vu la descente
is c'était quelqu'un qui avait tout
compris bien avant tout le monde
et étant donné qu'il est quand même la
personne qui même le plus et qui était
proche de moi il était malheureux et
finalement on a mis 100 personnes au
chômage et c'est pour ça que moi comme
je suis sam a pas cassé moi parce que
moi j'ai été vrai vis-à-vis de mon
public
quand j'ai fait la pac j'ai dit changer
de chèques changer de chaîne à l'est par
chantal goya c'est que vous m'aimez pas
c'était pour sauver tout le public des
petits qui m est proche d'eux vous
pensez une véritable volonté de nuire
derrière cette histoire chantal
attendait mais pourquoi tu auras chez
vous dire pour quelle raison patrick
savatier les migrants bas que rue envie
de vous
mir moi je pense que fin j'ai pas encore
la réponse exacte mais je pense que il y
avait de grandes jalousie qui
circulaient dont enfin les gens étaient
assez jaloux du succès et il ya des gens
qui m'a d'auray et des gens qui
n'aimaient pas c'est normal
aujourd'hui tout est bien qui finit bien
car tu es culte est tué
une star pour les gosses tu accule pour
les adultes est tué hyper populaire dont
j'aime bien tu as envie de faire un duo
toi tu as des inégalée chantal non je
t'emmerde
aujourd'hui à patrick sabatier s'il
était invité vivant qui me représente sa
maîtresse d'école
ah oui j'ai jamais vu mais c'est
qu'elles existent mais qu'elle n'est pas
si tutrice ça je le sais aussi que
c'était quelqu'un qui était payée par la
production s'est toujours demandé
comment ça se fait qu'un journaliste n'a
pas été plus loin dans cette histoire et
n'a pas été voir qui était cette femme
qui peut être très malheureuse dans son
coin parce qu'elle en a pris plein la
tronche aussi moins autant que moi hein
parce qu'elle est pas si tu tries
aujourd'hui tout va bien mais le
lendemain des nids sont toutes allées de
gestion vous fait aujourd'hui une
émission comme le jeu de la vérité par
exemple on craque et plus on va voir un
regard des mois vous pensez pas que
votre spectacle est nul à chier chantal
goya
non j'adore mon spectacle j'aurais
jusqu'au bout non dit j'adore mon
spectacle j'aurais jusqu'au bout marco
pensez pas que vous avez tissé les
enfants mais non je n'habite pas ou six
essais c'est votre choix vous pensez pas
qu à votre âge il faudrait les laisser
tranquilles et informe alors ça alors ça
y'a pas d'âge pour faire rêver kesselman
si sûr vous êtes endurci c'est bien je
me suis plus qu'on durcisse et que j'ai
gardé ma sensibilité mais j'ai un bon
parent avant devant ouais alors il ya un
truc extraordinaire dans le bouquin je
trouve c'est que vous fermez les yeux
sur les aventures de jean jacques debout
sur vous vous dites que vous l'avez
jamais trompé n'a jamais jamais parce
que non jamais jamais eu envie mais non
mais non parce que 1er mai que je
rencontre je parle que de jean-jacques
alors il en a ras-le-bol vous êtes
jamais dit celui-là je me le fais mais
non j'ai pas comme ça attendez avant que
voilà il faut des trois premiers vols il
faut c'est très compliqué ça se passe
pas comme ça va faire avoir des des
moments tendres en regardant quelqu'un
qui m'attendrait que aller tout de suite
dans un lit non s'adresse pas terminé ça
fait 40 ans que je devais alors c'est
mon éternelle fiancée pendant 40 ans
elle est magique aux dépens que je peux
pas le croire c'est pendant ces quarante
ans je ne connais pas encore je ne
connais pas encore et c'est mon
éternelle fiancée je n'arrêterai pas de
le dire
et puis je suis pas quelqu'un
le pen ne fait pas venir et que vous
avez envie d'y croire thierry merci
alain c'est non mais moi j'en chaque je
pense que notre histoire a toujours
durer parce que et durera pas ce que
j'ai toujours de laisser sa liberté de
cécile aime bien sortir voir des copains
myron bourré d bonjour madame c'est un
renouveau ça change à chaque fois j'ai
mis toute ma liberté d'abord il ya
jamais en tournée parce qu'il n'aime pas
voyager il a très peur dans l'avion et
les sens mal
j'ai fait les malins j'ai fait le monde
entier a bien verrouillé mais pas dans
la maison parce que les forces de gauche
équilibre dans ma tête
et puis moi je vais vous dire une chose
si je suis tellement tiers que je me
connais je deviendrai championne de
chistera ça devait arriver
ouais clac clac et puis on fait une
réunion au sommet et puis chacun
s'explique et puis ça va pas je prends
la balle et je m'en vais mais là ça fait
40 ans que ça dure ben oui il faut bien
que le corps exulte qu'on met le corps
et ça n'empêche pas que on peut très
bien ça doré et faire comme tout le
monde je vais placer déjà son mais
justement c'est ça qui est bien c'est
que comme on est souvent séparés on se
revoit et on s'adore d'accord parce que
si on est tout le temps collée tous
battus qu'à voler c'est vrai on n'a
jamais mis d'alliances mais enfin just à
l'antenne
on a quand même des enfants s'amusaient
pas non non ça fait plaisir
et maintenant qui met coin vous pouvez
la lune
voici ornella mutti
[Musique]
voilà
soit
très heureux de vous recevoir gratuit
vraiment allée à la fiche et will know
your enemy nom son prénom
ok et 1000mercis en dossier grazie mille
voilà ça vient de là il convient de
citer quoi toi c'est pas nul
non non c'est fou ça vient du prénom
non on n'a pas déjà gagnée le français
dit jacques a dit il levait les bras
là tu dois lever les bras m'a dit jack
adi lever les bras ouais bah non il faut
bien jacques a dit si je dis pas jack
adi qui bosse avec alors vas-y alors
vas-y vas-y jacadi lever les bras
voilà continue thierry cabine
ça va c'est ici ça va ça va c'est si bon
alors on vous on vous connaît pas ce
qu'on vous a vu beaucoup au cinéma mais
en fait on vous connaît pas très bien on
connaît pas très bien votre vie vous
êtes né à rome 1 à une date qui est
secrète
moi je lai non tu peux pas d'avancer ce
club âgés sais pas j'ai pas te dire tout
ça te dit quelque chose ce n'est pas
tout pas du tout je suis né le 9 mars
d'accord à rome l'année n'a aucune
importance aucune hockey ornella votre
vrai nom c'est francesca romana river
lycée je peux vous appeler frances mary
tout le monde connaît ils ont désormais
vous appellerai from software un cadre
bon alors père napoli ta mère estonienne
et et vos parents mais une relation
assez difficile c'était ce n'était pas
facile quand vous étiez petit
votre père vous gardent quand votre mère
s'en va allez une petite difficulté
difficultés et vous vous dit rien parce
qu'à l'époque les enfants disaient rien
à l'époque les enfants subissent et sans
rien dire parce qu'aujourd'hui ils
disent oui pourquoi les bas non son
droit qu'est quand les appétits les
souffrances de les enfants des parents
qu'ils ont des problèmes ils sont et
échangent les caractères peut-être après
tu dis mais ça ça veut rien dire de dire
est ce que tu sens je pense qu'il ya une
différence
ça vous a marqué bout oui
oui oui alors en plus votre père meurt
vous êtes assez jeune à ce moment là
vous avez 12 ans 1
donc une enfance assez difficile
finalement oui il ya pire quoi ouais et
depuis vous cherchez toujours le père
chez vos amours non pour un moment
peut-être oui maintenant non non non non
c'est fini fini sa mère de chercher
plutôt plus jeunes oui on aime à
rappeler temps perdu oui parce que là le
type qui vous est il a dix ans de moins
et benoît oui stéphane ont ils argué la
jetée panneau cédez golez
15 sur vettel avant j'avais fait via
lequel il a 15 ans et palau bien sûr
alors voilà ensuite fait remarquer par
donc le fameux damiano d'anna génie deux
associés une cloche
voilà c'est bien alors le premier film
s'appelle et c'est normal la femme la
plus belle
la moe la poubelle et alors c'est
terrible parce que pour faire pleurer
dans le film il vous bat avec un avec un
ceinturon
mais qui va dit tout ça c'est vraiment
c'est pas vrai we say say say vous avez
des traces pendant deux ans mais on va
peut-être encore aujourd'hui mais ce
n'est pas ce qu'on veut c'est une façon
c'est un vieux cinéma italien
s'assassiner justement paie j'espère on
sait pas un c'est pas un si jamais on
sait jamais voilà désormais sont
bizarres à jeune quand vous dites sont
cantonnés 1
ils vont bien au delà vous enchaîner les
tournages et tout votre toute votre
adolescence ou de votre jeunesse se
passe à tourner finalement vous êtes pas
le temps de vivre vais un peu oublié de
vivre non mais ça c'est un peu extrême
quoi parce que c'est vrai que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé mais les autres est
allé à l'école alors c'était notre façon
d'être occupés mais j'ai sûrement vu ma
vie et j'espère mais vous vous êtes
amusé quand même oui le soir après le
tournage
non non les cernant qu'est ce qui fait
un bon jeu mais détourné la délimitation
de moi que je sors de la boîte
aux huit câbles tendus on va vous donner
une carte de deux bancs clients visitent
une ride appeler grâce à cette carte
francesca grâce à cette carte vous
pouvez revenir quand vous voulez mais
qu'est ce que tu as donné ta pas donné
bon client
et comme famille
[Applaudissements]
non
pourquoi
qui sait
[Applaudissements]
j'étais vie de dominique faire de bons
clients laurent école famille on était
sûr les grandes chaînes ce carnet désolé
je propose pour ce faire complètement
pardonner une pause bisous
[Musique]
bien alors on continue laurent si tu
perds mais quand monsieur donc la
première fois qu'on vous voit en france
quand chaises cassées en 75 dans la
dernière femme de marco ferreri avec
jarre depardieu mais vous devenu une
vedette vraiment internationale avec
alain delon dans mort d'un pourri de
georges lautner quoi je suis également
dans ce film tu es dans le film quand
mort d'un pourri non et non je fais un
figurant l'était à la gare montparnasse
on s'est croisé toute la journée et tu
montais les marches moi je la descendait
on est là tu n'avais pas de soutien
gorge et il m'a fait passer une journée
magnifique et dans le film de ferreri
ouais rappelons qu'elles coupent le sexe
de gérard depardieu avec un couteau
électrique ici out au couteau justement
réparti la cac
voilà des mois que c'est un beau cadeau
n'y pense jamais oui
je n'a pas le réflexe voilà donc mort
d'un pourri puis ensuite de skate dans
les nouveaux monstres et pis surtout moi
le film de vous que je préfère ces
contes de la folie ordinaire qui est un
film que que j'adore là vous mettez tout
le monde d'accord dans ce film voilà et
alors c'est marrant vous n'êtes jamais
allé à hollywood hollywood
oui elle répond non mais j'ai oui
j'étais mais tu vois il ya des choses
qui n'est pas tout à fait prêt tout
inferno un émoi rester là toute la vie
oubliez tout moi je suis un python et
européennes
c'est pourquoi pas un cadeau mais elle a
dit un truc génial francesca l'a dit
finalement les second rôles me dérange
pas parce que de toute façon dans la
vraie vie on est déjà un premier rôle
c'est une très belle phrase c'est vrai
dans ce dans sa propre vie on est son
premier rôle on s'entendrait bien tous
les deux n'ont jamais on a quelques
shows et une complicité entre nous et
oui conflit cheat à 6 608 behzad
[Applaudissements]
non
non je trouve que française 40 10100 est
devenu très équilibré c'est ce que c est
ce que c'est les vous ai fait une
analyse si j'ai fait analyser les effets
ça vous a équilibré ça vous a fait du
bien mam équilibrer ses mots un peu
difficile 1 - à comprendre mais on
cherche décès et mecquois dérobé une
harmonie dans soi même ses sacs et après
c'est utile le solide équilibre c'est un
peu difficile à savoir
donc vous avez l'air très bien la wii
non catherine barma na li qui l'avoué
elle est insupportable et ou pas du tout
vous êtes pas du tout
non non c'est quelqu'un qu'on a
travaillé ensemble genève et new haven
en hiver
oui oui catherine louis bien alors
équilibrée aussi par le bouddhisme et le
bouddhisme hindouisme c'est un espagnol
pardon il bouddhisme les attentes des
oui non mais là j'ai pas le bout du
dalaï lama
non c'est un bouddhisme japonais salé
bouddhisme japonais voilà est-ce que
c'est quoi c'est la soka gakkai c'est ça
oui
ac c'est bien cette parole ce membre à
te donne de l'énergie peu tabou oui ça
se voit c'était pas moi j'espère c'est
de cette prière donne de l'énergie c'est
vrai mais oui on va essayer non tu
commences que vous appelez cela c'est
vrai
[Musique]
ça monte aussi pas monter ça ça dépend
de chacun non je crois qu'elle a percé à
jour mais vous savez que en france il ya
des gens qui pensent que c'est une secte
quand même mais tout ce qui en connaît
pas tous que
ça ce n'est pas ça fait c'est comme ça
mais ce n'est pas une secte pas du tout
parce qu'il ya un grand liberté il n'y a
pas de de l'obligation mehiaoui il n'y a
pas de personnes nées
des eaux claires il n'y a pas des
prêtres il n'y a pas quelque chose comme
ça c'est tous on a tous ensemble comme
chacun sait non d'un beau hein
la japon c'est un grand monsieur wôyô
dira et sa clique aide à quelqu'un qui
est reconnu par tout le monde comme un
des grands fortunés cas ça vous fait du
bien
oui c'est déjà pas mal c'est l'essentiel
je crois vous pourriez beaucoup
m'apporter ok je suis pas trop vieux
pour vous bien équilibré aussi par vos
trois enfants la première c'est maïté
qu'est née quand vous aviez 19 ans le
père c'est comme votre âge il est secret
le père de nike et oui il est secret et
s'est créé il est secret elle s'appelle
nike et ribéry les secrets le père
s'était passé là c'est là mon nom ça
veut dire que les pères elle n'a pas
voulu donner un nom voilà donc on est
passé créé il n'hésiterait pas voilà on
n'en parle pas c'est tout non moi je
sais qui c'est mais
[Musique]
quand sardou et alors nike a fait de
vous une grand-mère une très jolie
grand-mère d'ailleurs je dois dire celle
émergents tandis qu'à l'écran merde
c'est à dire l'âge et la petite fille
qui vient d'être maman y'a pas très
malin et là ils l'offrent l'enfant de
l'humanité s'appelle à cache cache
ça veut dire quoi que chalon ciel en
quoi un alien un nom indien devrait
d'indiens l'indien des indes
ouais avec toiture ben ouais d'accord
voilà alors est-ce que depuis que vous
êtes beaucoup mais vous savez faire un
bon café
une référence à une pub française
tu peux pas comprendre parce que non et
private joke franco français voilà mais
les italiennes tous tous des familles
tanière
est-ce que depuis que cette grand mère
vous avez peur de la canicule l'été
mais quoi
non non tu vois que c'est moi le méchant
mais tu te trompes non la canicule l'été
il fait chaud elles et les vieilles
demeures
ah non moi je suis pas morte cette
dernière était 7 est terrible c'est
terrible quinze mois un mois à vers les
choses ça va très bien non c'est
l'effroi que mathieu est ce que depuis
que vous êtes grand mère vous pensez de
chirurgie esthétique mais j'aurais pensé
à ça même ça être une grammaire ça veut
rien dire être grammaire c'est bien ça
va vous n'êtes pas besoin de chirurgie
esthétique toute façon aujourd'hui mais
m je sais pas peut-être oui mais jusqu'à
le moment que je ne sens pas la
nécessité
je ne fais pas même si j'ai besoin
peut-être que j'ai besoin et je m'en
fiche
non non non non mais c'est dommage parce
que stefano le jul de francesca et
chirurgie esthétique comme pas ya
l'appartement trailer mais écoute tu ne
penses pas que ça c'est très beau très
beau d'être maître par quelqu'un qui a
une à une conception de la beauté et
même même si je suis pas 25 ans 27 ça va
encore bon alors voilà alors toute façon
vous voilà le problème avec vous je
crois qu'on peut le dire franchement je
crois que là on peut se dire les choses
ce temps-là de la nuit vous avez besoin
de vivre avec un homme
les histoires d'une nuit comme ça ça
vous plaît pas vous ce qu'il faut si une
relation suivie avec un homme c'est vrai
française mais non mais c'est vrai mais
juste une nuit c'est pas son truc de
nuit peut-être qu'on va prendre une
semaine
vous avez vous avez déclaré l'orgasme
pour l'orgasme
je m'en fiche oui moi c'est pareil je
fais toi non ah bon ça ce matin que ça
ouais mais tu vois par exemple exemple
c'est différent que c'est nécessaire et
par lequel niveau mais peut-être que les
ans mais en plus besoin de ces décharges
et des quelques façons ils sont plus
victime des vrais descendants une [ __ ] à
la place du cerveau
souvent oui souvent laurent fin mais
sans plus équilibré il peut mettre
certains choses à côté parce qu'il lui
faut à francesca c'est du romantisme
parce que présente la chose c'était dans
un peep show par exemple une chose tous
les aides alors là on était devant le
peep show si on regarde un film porno
latella vous dites après chaque fois je
me sens sale vous dites seule salle e
c'est vrai quoi prendre un vélo
maintenant j'ai maintenant je sais pas
moi j'aime pas j'aime vivre certaines
choses avec les choeurs ces principes
c'est terrible j'ai toujours les
affaires des autres choses moi j'aime
pas mais chacun son truc
moi je préfère les femmes comme vous
kaka est maintenant lenny kravitz
[Musique]
ceci est
[Applaudissements]
la meilleure façon
la meilleure façon de présenter lenny
kravitz à ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
encore c'est ça didier
[Musique]
oui
où
[Musique]
non
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
mik
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier
mais qui vous
mardi nous
[Musique]
elle émigre à l'iss
[Applaudissements]
alors alors on est là connaissent et
lenny kravitz voulez mais ouais moi
aussi
attention c'est un homme à femmes c'est
un grand séducteur attention ornella
faut pas rester tout seul avec lui alors
ouais c'est vrai vous croyez pas non non
non je crois qu'en fait vous êtes très
galant mais vous avez quand même
beaucoup de succès avec les femmes les
nids c'est vrai yoann succès
[Applaudissements]
j'ai aussi mal que toi peut-être bien
alors c'est vrai que la chanson lady
fait référence à votre aventure avec
nicole kidman qui vous a dit ça jette au
balancier avant avant ça je ne dirai
rien réponse non je connais c'est la
réponse avant de vous poser la question
mais je suis obligée de vous la posez
vous avez eu des tas de deux conquêtes
amoureuses duquel vous avez parlé
vanessa paradis madonna on sait pas trop
kylie minogue natalie imbruglia nicole
kidman
alors on cherche toujours à savoir
évidemment quel est votre secret pour
ginette garcin pour séduire toutes les
notes garçons
comment c'est là c'est la wii me scotche
parce que ginette garcin moi je n'ai lu
je suis plus haut mais je n'ai lu avec
parce que j'aime les mecs
non mais vous avez sûrement un secret
pour avoir ce succès acquis sur les
quais avec les femmes vous avez 20
secret alors dernièrement vous avez dit
dans la presse que vous portiez jamais
de sous vêtements est ce que vous pensez
que ça ça aide avec les familles aille à
john waters gens ne portent pas mais
qu'est ce que ça a à voir avec le reste
je sais pas non non je ne suis que moi
même toi non plus de vous dire moi j'en
porte pas mais je n'ai pas le même
succès lui ça ça vous ça vous dégoûte
ama qui portent pas de sous-vêtements
vos parce que ni les nîmois n'emportant
je vous dis tout de suite
ok c'est la même chose avec le sang
c'est pas beaucoup c'est pas un problème
heureusement bien narré mois on a deux
beaux calbète bernard blanco ouvert le
sien oui blanc col ouvert toujours
bernard très bonnes vannes thierry
stoehr donne une deuxième vie merci aux
merci non non
non nous donne une grosse [ __ ] mais
c'est très bien qu'offrant de toi tu es
comme ça tel quoi toi non maintenant
j'ai la carte de banque liant à et avant
que ça c'est le thème qui me tourner
vers n'a pas lui donner une carte aussi
qu'est ce qu'il donne à bernard une
bonne carte avec toi voyons voir carte
de mauvais clients c'est le cas des
collectors banon pas bernard donc pas de
sous-vêtements et est ce que vous dites
je porte jamais de parfums m'étais
jamais de parfums vous dites ça pue
est-ce que c'est compatible les deux
[Rires]
gants de cros g
c'est incroyable impasse de la
philosophie au parfum et sous-vêtements
j'adore alors non je ne pas sombre c'est
tout ouais bah je vois là un outil qui
portent de parfums te le demande
d'arrêter non les finitions de l'aude a
pas de problème mais l'argent qu'ils
portent pas de parfum ça vous préférez
qu'ils emportent qu'ils en ont marre
elle s'en fout du monde c'est un vrai
que je crois c'est quelqu'un intéressant
ça quelque chose d'autre je serais pas
en train de flancher sur lui toi la
grande qualité de lenny kravitz peut le
dire la grande qualité de lenny kravitz
en dehors des chansons qui fait bien
entendu c'est qu'il peut se retenir
c'est à dire il peut rester deux mois
sans faire l'amour un essai de deux mois
sans faire la bonne et là ça fait trois
mois ils échouent
c'est vrai dans l'est ni lait ni c'est
pas le genre à se jeter sur les filles
bêtement comme nous tu vois c'est vrai
les miens deux mois tout le monde je
sais pas d'où vous sortez ces infos mais
bon il ya des époques où il faut faire
une pause et vraiment se concentrer sur
soi même se concentrait sur sortir issu
à l'italie fait face à l'ancien no sex
nos sexes arrête toi toi il est entré il
va il va vous filmer en est là faites
attention il est gelé vue c'est la
dernière mode
oh là là t'as vu ça mais remonter je
suis bon service public oui je suis là
je vais dire il est arrivé là en amour
ans qui lui avait donné des ordres alors
les mii sur l'irak vous avez pris des
positions très anti guerre vous avez
même enregistré une chanson avec une
popstar irakienne qui s'appelle khadim
altaïr avec un libanais et un
palestinien et la chanson s'appelle we
want peace
[Musique]
c'est une chanson qui s'appelle we want
piste on peut trouver sur le site rock
the vote à une chanson que j'ai fait
contre la guerre en irak ne va pas vous
rendre très populaire ça aux etats-unis
non non pas vraiment en fait
aux etats unis les gens pas très bien
accueilli cette déclaration surtout
qu'il y avait une machine de propagande
qui détruisait tout sur son passage et
donc si vous étiez américain contre la
gorge contre la guerre vous n'étiez pas
patriote vous n'apportez pas votre
soutien votre pays et dans le new york
post ils sont inutiles
il y avait ma photo à côté de celle de
saddam hussein en dix ans nous étions en
écosse tout simplement parce que j'avais
chanté une chanson qui lisait nous
voulons la paix avec un chanteur irakien
sous n'importe quoi
dans les biberons soir moi j'ai un
désaccord majeur avec baffie ce soir
c'est quoi c'est qu'il a froid et que je
meurs de chaux et fait chaud il fait une
chaleur de bépanda la boutique qui a
froid tu fait rempart de ton corps là tu
vas le lot chercher une petite laine tu
ne touches pas à l'air conditionné
continue thierry à ses jours c'est mon
blouson on est là merci
donc dit aussi de brancher votre talent
bernard henri lévy mans vos proches
votre argent vous êtes riche
je ne sais pas il ya un bug y paraît
jeudi faisant les irrigants france en
france un intellectuel qui a les moyens
dix ans c'est moins bien vu que les
états unis écoutez d'abord en france il
y à des écrivains qui ont eu un peu
d'argent c'est arrivé andré gide
avec cette réputation il était valery
larbaud michel leiris raymond roussel
c'est pas une chose complètement anormal
plus en france non ça dépend ce qu'on en
fait ça dépend voilà il est écrit quoi
valery larbaud s'il a échappé contre il
a écrit notamment un livre que vous
auriez avantage à lire qui s'appelle le
journal de barna boot2 et qui est un
très beau livre d'un aboud partisanerie
pour je me ridiculiser le libraire on a
beau c'est en tout cas ce soir avant le
libraire chez ardisson ou oth à la fin
on va parler de livres parce que votre
vie bernard lévy suscite quand même pas
mal de curiosité
il ya trois livres en préparation sur
vous 3,3 biographie non autorisée
j'imagine non à totalement non
autorisées ouais mais ça c'est là ça
c'est l'habitude maintenant où ses
lacets la manie cd des livres de flics
et de délation
l'auteur d'un de ses livres c'est pas un
auteur abstrait il s'appelle philippe
cohen c'est l'homme qui a écrit avec p
ans se livrent dégueulasse contre le
monde
ce livre où on allait chercher des
histoires sur le passé des pères afin de
confondre les filles six secondes lisez
noir sur blanc comme dans la presse
d'extrême droite des années 30 que le
monde c'était le journal de l'anti
france donc c'est l'auteur de ce livre
là sur vaud a eu l'idée saugrenue voilà
d'aller fouiller dans ma vie dans mon
passé dans mon présente ses bras et de
raconter ma biographie est en effet
c'est totalement non autorisée je trouve
cette idée détestable et je trouve que
les voilà c'est pas sur le terrifiant de
savoir qu'il ya trois personnes qui
passent leur temps à essayer de trouver
des secrets sur vous c'est extrêmement
désagréable c'est un peu vous savez c
on a l'impression d'une sorte de vol de
vautours et c'est assez curieux alors je
reçois des coups de téléphone des coups
de téléphone d'amis qui m'alerte des
coups de téléphone d'anciens amis qui se
souviennent des coups de téléphone
d'ennemis qui peut en une espèce de
dernier réflexe d'élégance et qui me
disent j'ai reçu un appel de philippe
cohen ou d'un autre type un journaliste
du canard enchaîné qui s'appelle nicolas
beau qui est un mauvais journaliste d'où
le nom d'où le nom absolument et en
effet il ya il ya un sentiment bizarre
se sentir épié se sentir avec en plus
chez ce genre de biographe qui sont qui
sont moins des écrivains et que des
encore une fois que des clones mentalité
de flics c'est vraiment poète vos
papiers
la phrase d'aragon écrivain vos papiers
il ya une sorte de manille de donner un
sens à tous une folie du sens à mes
alors à 22 ans vous avez fait ceci mais
alors ça explique cela est une espèce de
déluge d'interprétation paranoïaque qui
sont totalement absurde
il ya ya ya deux manières de traiter ce
genre de livre le débat d'idées pas de
problème ma personne
pas de problème non plus
en revanche les proches et notamment les
disparus ceux qui ne sont plus là pour
répliquer eux-mêmes qu'il aurait peut
être fait avec plus de vigueur que je ne
le ferai moi-même ça c'est vrai que je
prends je prendrai très mal voyants
viennent y toucher et que là je ne
réagirai pas comme quand même ça donne
mais comme un bon écrivain quand le
madep à dire de la liberté d'expression
tous azimuts il ya des choses que je ne
supporterais pas que l'on aborde il a
raison il fait froid que je sens qu'elle
a qu'à la très froid je demande qu'on
arrête les repositionner est-ce qu'on
peut arrêter là conditionné
c'est un john maintenant qu'on va se
faire souffler la faire non mais c'est
exactement
c'est ce que je viens donc confiant j'ai
vu comment elle le regarde et j'ai
compris qu'en voilà il est malin il est
forte et comment il a fait ça bord est
savoureux quand même un petit peu agacé
de te laisser le privilège
laurent est ce que tu leur match n'est
pas terminé est ce que tu peux
déshabiller francesca oui on retient
tout alors je fais pas le voyage pour
emile 26000 est là bien alors le
reportage vous amène souvent dans les
endroits les plus dangereux de la
planète
vous avez peur de mourir j'ai peur de
mourir comme chacun j'ai bien sûr peur
de mourir mais il m'arrive
oui quand je me trouve quand je me
trouve au nigeria dans certaines des
scènes que je rapporte dans livres ou
quand je me trouve au burundi dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure il m'arrive
comme tous les reporter de guerre comme
tous ceux qui mettent leur vie un tout
petit peu en jeu pour rapporter avec les
dents un peu de vérité on a évidemment
parfois un peu peur de mourir bien sûr
on va vous faire une interview bernard
lévy si vous mourriez demain
c'est ça c'est une nouveauté ça dans
l'émission c'est une nouveauté
et si je suis et attendez si je suis
superstitieux si vous êtes superstitieux
vous pour quitter le plateau
immédiatement vous avez de la chance je
ne veux pas sûr quand il est trop
intelligent pour actionner son nom le
saviez vous mais qu'est ce que vous
voudriez absolument faire ce soir si
vous deviez mourir demain la même chose
que tous les jours la poursuite d
habitude ce le miracle d'un jour de plus
près inchangée surtout ne rien changer
dans les bras de qui aimeriez-vous
passer cette dernière nuit comme toutes
les nuits précédentes dans les bras de
la femme de ma vie qui aimeriez-vous
encore une dernière fois au téléphone
s'il est question terrible qui
j'aimerais entendre pour la dernière
fois au téléphone
vous êtes avec ariel mais pas besoin
d'entendre de marque à l'antenne vous
êtes avec ariel celle l'année cela a été
si souvent fait qu'elle ait pas de votre
niveau j'espère qu'elle sera coupée au
montage c'est pas mon nom ma part tout
cas là rien pourquoi la saison plaît
rien ne peut le faire chier je vais pas
la couper au montage par nab août déjà
c'était une histoire c'est la guerre que
tu veux battre coiffer à fait vrai
on fait les potes je dirais un ancien
ami avec lequel je me suis débrouillé
puis 10 ou 20 à temps voilà et avec
lequel j'aurai sûrement le désir de ses
biens de dissiper un malentendu puisque
souvent les brouilles sont des brouilles
de malentendus est-ce que vous
essaieriez décrire la dépêche
pour la presse la dépêche afp là vous
êtes naïf mon cher thierry ardisson
parce que la dépêche elle est pour
chacun d'entre nous d'ailleurs est déjà
écrite pour ornella mutti pour tirer là
disons même pour bah si elle est déjà
écrite ce qu'on appelle dans les
journaux et dans les rédactions l'avion
de 3,1 alors vous aimeriez qu'on dise
quoi de vous au journal télévisé demain
soir le compagnon d'arielle dombasle
s'est éteint ce matin ça déjà c'est pas
mal mais si j'ai droit encore un tout
petit temps d'antenne ja badges et
j'aimerais oui bien sûr et puis
j'aimerais donc on énumère peut-être le
titre de mes livres
six journalistes en or pas comme quand
on compte les moutons ce possible aussi
vous aimeriez un hommage de la part de
clients cimetière parce que nous
estimons excusez moi mais bon j'ai lu
dans récidive quelques discours vous
avez fait dans les cimetières
j'espère mourir avant vous vous ferez de
bien c'est d'accord
la biomasse est un ami il donnera pas du
tout dans mon enterrement je voudrais
dire des vannes mois s'il fait le way je
pourrais venir pour l'oraison funèbre
d'abord un hommage par qui sérieux non
s'il n'était pas s'ils n'étaient pas
partis avant moi donc dans l'hypothèse 1
j'aurais peut-être demander à benny lévy
ou alors autre hypothèse il ya deux
villes où on m'aime bien il y à sarajevo
où comme une ennemie initial bhl veux le
dire bosnie herzégovine livre et puis à
jérusalem
j'aurais bien vu de petite veillée
funèbre comme ça quelques papas beaucoup
de monde mais quelques quelques
personnes quelques secondes de silence
chip cox a raillé vous pas forcément
centrale par les personnes comme moi y
en a sara lee des briques des vieux
copains à jérusalem comment c'est
quelques secondes de silence dans les
deux cas vous relire y est qu'elle livre
si vous mourriez demain le journal du
lendemain le journal du lendemain de la
mort parole réponse énigmatique oui je
sais pas je me suis dit [ __ ] on voit
quand y'a plein de bouquins dont je
connais pas je vais fermer ma gueule
vous réveillez quel film à part le mien
bien sûr et le tien non je devrais
commencer par le sien et du corps à
l'hypothèse dit les kora hypothèse
encore une fois que vous envisagez que
je imaginer je crois je me mettrais
devant la télévision jeux je zapperai
comme un fou toute la nuit tous les
films puis tout l'été mais le trait sur
canalsat et j'enverrai un paquet vous et
couturiers quelle musique musique
musique du jour c'est à dire si c'est le
matin les bruits de la ville si c'est la
nuit vous n'êtes pas très musicale elle
s'en plaignait bernard n'a pas vous
allez pouvoir écouter de la musique à la
maison ça lui manque
elle nous l'a dit de mon vivant les
noubas qu'elle fait en boîte depuis que
tu es décédé
comment elle s'éclate ça ça m'énerve
elle revit un lay up jungle elle
revivait vous trouveriez ça injuste de
partir si tôt sa vie il ya il y avait un
mot merveilleux je crois que c'est de
maurice ronet dans feu follet qui disait
un type comme moi ne devrait jamais
moyens et c'est tellement vrai un type
comme comme nous comme nous est-ce que
vous accepteriez de donner certains de
vos organes certains de mes organes
vivre là je pensais pas tout de suite au
sexe s'il a voulu garder si on ne sait
jamais si des fois il ya un type à la
résurrection des corps si elle existe et
si elle survit je donnerai plus tôt
plutôt mon âme
mais sinon vous donnez rien pas de recul
pour le kosovo vers la révolte chemise
blanche voudriez qu'on en fasse quoi de
votre collection de chemises blanches
moi c'est quoi ton vous me répondez
d'abord sur la collection de tee shirt
noir et je vous répondrai sur la
collection de chemises blanches bien moi
je l'aiderai ce que vous en faites c'est
moi je les donne à emmaüs
il aimait jamais l'abbé pierre mais et
c'est quoi ce blanc alors le secret de
ce blanc a qu'une question de semaines
c'est blanc et comment tu fais pour ça
que quand les cheveux vous le saurez pas
ce que tu as encore beaucoup de cheveux
oui c'est vrai ça c'est alors quand tu
es un fixateur commentateurs gagner
un fixateur matin et soir avec un
acharnement terrible je passe ma vie à
ça j'écris à peine tu vois regarde est
ce que vous penseriez avoir eu une belle
vie
écoutez je crois que je dirais vous
savez c'est le dernier mot de ces le
dernier mot de romain gary qui est un
autre écrivain que j'ai un peu connu et
que j'ai beaucoup aimé et dans son
dernier livre qui s'appelle vie et mort
d'emile ajar
il a ce moment extraordinaire c'est les
derniers à c'est la dernière phrase du
livre je me suis beaucoup amusé au
revoir et merci à vous réagissez comme
ans aux attaques dont bernard-henri lévy
et est l'objet en ce moment à travers
tous ces livres qui sortent comme ça les
uns après ça me semble un peu
abracadabrant qu'il y en est tellement
il y en a eu deux il y en a encore
quatre en préparation voilà mais mais
mais heureusement je crois que les gens
n'ont pas tellement envie de lire des
gossip méchant vue par le petit bout de
la lorgnette et donc à mon avis les les
livres ne marche pas je ne sais pas
assez c'est extrêmement enfin il ya oui
c'est comme une comme un animal très
beau qui courent et puis il ya toute une
meute derrière qui veut le montre dès sa
première émission télévision quand on
l'a vu beau pardonnez moi mais il est
beau et avec son décolleté tout ça c'est
pour les gens non non il est imberbe
bon et alors alors oui c'est vrai ça
comment se crée tout habitué les gens se
sont déchaînés bonbons non mais là je
ris voilà mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
voilà c'est très très méga désagréable
et puis pourquoi pourquoi les gens quand
même autre chose à faire qu'à écrire des
livres comme ça à quoi ça sert ariel on
va faire une interview par amour
[Musique]
arielle dombasle est ce que par amour
comme si si vous présenteriez des
maîtresses à votre mari eh bien écoutez
je ne sais pas mais si c'était le seul
moyen de le garder peut-être que je le
ferai que ce beau mais également non
mais vide alors là je n'ai aucune
réponse ailleurs
[Musique]
oh que c'est beau mega man je voudrais
toujours être là favori enfin j'en
rêverai je prierai hélas je te les
agences est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de
tuer
ah ben ça bien sûr le cacher bien sûr
bien sûr a pas de problème a même aucun
problème et je dirais même ma josé même
nom mais je dirais même que c'est moi
qui l'ait tué ah oui mais on le sait
magnifique qu'il a une chance en plein
air c'est le plus vert de la bande les
gens qui est ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à vous mettre à la drogue
ou l'arrêter
je dirais que je serai tout pour d'abord
en dissuader landais mais je crois que
par amour ou on est prêt à tout
d'ailleurs
moi je me souviens voyez d'antan dans
mon enfance où j'habite et le mexique
alors je me rappelle que mon père avait
fait prendre des champignons
hallucinogènes à ma mère est donc
finalement oui bien sûr je fais pas une
mycose et documents llr elle avait
essayé donc et je crois que lui avait
fait un trait merveilleux voyage de
champignons hallucinogènes et elle par
amour avait suivi et je pense que ça
c'était assez mal passé pour elle voilà
est-ce que par amour vous feriez la
laissiez marianne à votre avis est-ce
que par un mot vous seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg oui bien sûr mais bon si
bernard henri penser si bernard au rite
en qui rigole ça va mais nommés mais
s'il avait envie tout à coup d'une femme
à tresques oui oui voilà un beau c'est
bel et bien je prendrai les 17 kilos
mais je crois que c'est formidable mais
j'avais vu l'amiral j'avais vu quand
même à quel point les allées et dévoué à
son amour mais merde
c'est pas sûr que fait l'adaptation
féminine qui est extraordinaire
ariel est ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à vivre avec bernard et la
maîtresses que vous lui auriez présenter
je sais pas j'ai j'ai connu un cas où un
homme vivait en effet avec sa femme et
sa maîtresse mais à la cave le dire
proche proche de vous oui des gens
connus non mais attends que des gens
proches de vous sérieusement en réalité
à un moment donné non j'habitais le
mexique et et mon père était un très
grand séducteur rue beaurepaire très
beau très beau et un moment donné mais
j'étais très enfants est très petit
alors je ne suis pas sûr j'ai capté des
choses mais peut-être pas vraiment mais
il y avait une femme qui était la
dernière se disait la dernière
descendante du dernier empereur aztèque
qui s'appelait saute schild qui était
une ravissante métisse aux cheveux tirés
en arrière extraordinairement belle et
qui habitait chez moi au dessus de ma
chambre d'ailleurs et ma mère était
vivante et donc je me suis toujours posé
des question de comment est ce que cette
femme vivait à nous maintenant c'est
votre mère l'a accepté ça en fait je ne
sais pas ouais et donc est ce que moi je
serai capable je sais pas mais tout ça
est en même temps vous savez très très
douloureux c'est parce que on était très
amoureux sont même bien sûr paris c'est
bien tout le l'idée de cette interview
c'est par amour est-ce que par amour par
exemple vous seriez prête à vendre votre
corps si bernard henri lévy vous le
demandez à des qualités un attention
alors je dirais d'abord je ne suis pas
achetable ouais non quand on aura dit le
prix
j'ai repris les mettra la banane est ce
que par amour vous seriez prête à ne pas
faire l'amour pendant trois ans alors
candidat commence maintenant
top chrono ben ça c'est terrible parce
qu'en effet mais vous voyez quand on lit
les grands mystiques tu m'aimes et saufs
juana inés de la cruz
par exemple au hasard je pense qu'on
arrive à un certain plaisir dans
l'abstinence aussi directrice mme à ce
qu'on appelle oui et je pense qu'il ya
une forme d'extase aussi d'un de désiré
et de se dire non je suis plus fort que
mon désir je ne je ne cède pas
je reste comme ça on maîtrise de
moi-même trois ans real quand même oui
je sais c'est le gaz elle et moi non
mais mais mais il peut être qu'on arrive
à une sorte de forme d'extase de douleur
aussi
ou alors tu peux passer en manuel nom
revient où vous croyez vous à ça vous
voyez ce qu'elle dit là que l'abstinence
amène à l'extase amiral ça serait quand
même ça peut être une satisfaction
nous ne sommes pas des animaux ainsi si
nous sommes des mères pensent pas ça du
tout le sera peut-être des mammifères
nous ne sommes pas des animaux il opère
mais on peut aussi simplement fantasme
est très très fort et on est dans une
sorte de rêve éveillé dans l'imaginaire
et avoir une sorte de forme d'extase des
champignons toujours
il ya un livre autour de vous qui a très
bien marché c'est le livre de justine
votre fille je suis très très fier delà
du succès littéraire de mes filles ouais
succès littéraire c'est un c'est un
véritable écrivain et c'est pas fréquent
vous savez pour un bon moi je suis un
père et un père très très aisément de ma
fille et puis je suis aussi un écrivain
et c'est pas souvent dans l'histoire de
la littérature
un père et un fils ou un père et une
fille écrivains samar élections de
demain rarement et alexandre dumas oui
il ya quelques cas oui c'est vrai là
vous êtes bon justine lévy bon soir ça
va vous êtes né à paris en 1974
vous êtes prénommé justin juliette
justin c'est votre père qui vous appelle
comme ça bernard henri lévy juliette
c'est votre mère isabelle doutreluigne
mannequin vedette des années 60
photographiée à l'époque par sarah moon
helmut newton qui deviendra une
militante acharnée de la cause de
féministes qui s'est aussi beaucoup
défoncé et qui vous confiez votre père
vous dit en parlant de bernard henri
lévy bhl est à la fois mon père et ma
mère ils comptent double est ce que vous
pouvez faire des réponses plus courte
parce que j'ai peur qu'on déborde un peu
donc quand l école on vous demande la
profession de votre père vous dit
philosophe et quand on vous dit c'est
quoi
vous dites c'est quelqu'un qui passe à
la télé je trouve ça c'est génial
à l'adolescence vous avez l'impression
d'être à vilain petit canard
et vous dites je suis encore aujourd'hui
dans le excusez moi dans leurs excuses
et moi d'être
ne pas toujours être à la hauteur de
plein de choses oui dans le excusez moi
dans la culpabilité en permanence pardon
vous avez l'air tendu crispé anxieuse
j'aime tellement la télévision et
particulièrement pas cette émission
non mais j'aime bien cette émission mais
c'est c est pour la regarder voilà donc
à l'adolescence cette impression comme
ça de très vilains petits canards et
puis c'est le grand amour vous tombé
raide dingue amoureuse de raphaël
enthoven fils de jean paul enthoven
éditeur et ami de votre père vous dites
on avait envie de faire un petit couple
on se disait nous on va y arriver
c'est vrai qu'on les parents ont été
tous les deux on avait tous les deux des
parents divorcés on se disait que nous
on allait réussir là où il avait échoué
voilà comment une enfant de parents une
version vous marier en 1996 et cinq ans
plus tard pour le passage à l'an 2000
vous partez en vacances à marrakech dans
la maison de votre père il y à là
arielle dombasle jean-paul antho veine
le père de votre mari avec sa maîtresse
du moment carla bruni des rafales entre
vennes donc va vous quitter pour elle
pour carla bruni le divorce sera
prononcé dans l'année voilà pour la
dimension je dirais pis paul et name
dropping de la sphère leurs ailes c'est
la littérature ça s'appelle rien de
grave c'est super bien écrit avec plein
de phrases d'auteurs comme on aime et
une flavour françoise sagan dorothy
parker
rien de grave ça veut dire quoi c'est
pas la fin du monde non plus c'est ça
ouais c'est une éthique c'est comme ça
que c'est dans la vie rien de grave
même quand les choses ne sont en tout
petit peu c'est une manière de ne pas
alourdir ce qui est déjà lourd marie
françoise leclerc dans le point à
trouver une formule qui résume assez
bien le titre et votre façon de faire
raconter ces drames sans à faire un
drame c'est ça une bonne phrase alors le
pitch du bouquin louise et adrien cm
donc depuis la fin de l'adolescence
jusqu'au jour où adrien rencontre paul à
la jeune maîtresse de son père et la
peau la brise le coeur de louise en lui
volant adria et bien on s'aperçoit qu'en
fait tout n'était pas si simple entre
entre louise et adrien avant même la
rencontre avec paula puisque adrien
avait demandé à luis d'avorter sous
prétexte qu'ils n'étaient pas encore
faits pour avoir un enfant d'avoir t il
ont décidé ensemble d'avorter parce que
ce n'était pas le moment donc il y avait
quand même déjà des fêlures dans le
cristal quoi ouais ouais
bien sûr ouais l'enfant dit vous aurez
s'étend maintenant il s'appellerait
aurélien il aurait sept ans elle
regrette louise ça quand on regrette en
est malheureux deux fois non elle
regrette pas je sens qu'on va bien
rigoler ce soir et je sais pas pourquoi
une bonne des compétences et la louise
va s'accrocher aux amphétamines
après cet avortement vous voulez lire ou
je lis parce qu'en fait ce qui est
intéressant un livre c'est de les lire
c'est pas de raconter ouais c'est ça
c'est difficile de commenter son propre
roman aussi ouais c'est après
l'avortement que je me suis vraiment mis
à croire qu'il me manquait quelque chose
pas à ces femmes pas assez adulte pas
assez regard de tueuse pas assez bien
pour avoir un enfant avec lui pas la
hauteur passe et où je me suis senti
tout à coup la superbe comme une
chenille recalé à l'examen papillon et
c'est comme ça qu'un jour en fouillant
dans les tiroirs du bureau de mon père
je suis tombé sur ces vitamines pour le
cerveau je savais qu'il en prenait
parfois pour travailler pour rester
éveillé finir ses livres je savais que
ça rende énerve concentré irascible
rapide
j'avais toujours su qu'elle était là
dans la caverne d'ali papa mais ça ne
m'intéressait pas plus que ça je passais
devant sans les voir lui-même d'ailleurs
n'en parler jamais sauf avec ses copains
écrivain quand ils s'échangeaient leurs
recettes et leurs dosage alors que là je
me suis dit c'est génial c'est peut-être
ça la solution je n'aurai qu'à les avoir
partout tout le temps avec moi ces
petites pilules magiques les
premièrement je serai brillante malines
passionnante et deuxièmement ce sera un
peu de papa en moi ce sera comme s'ils
étaient avec moi on sera deux on est
forcément plus fort à deux car ça
m'aidera être à la hauteur
il faut bien ça pour être digne dalle
rien c'est comme ça que tout a commencé
chacko des bulles les amphétamines louve
le monde
au début c'est extraordinaire comme
elles se sont intelligente et vive elle
rougit plus elle est pas mal à l'aise
comme la jeunesse filles en ce moment
elle est là elle ferait à gérer un
fournisseur de dieu sur le plateau ce
serait merveilleux mais met en effet au
bout de quelques mois c'est c'est tout à
fait pareil d'abord c'est ça la rend
malade quand le chien ensuite aller
s'est passé pas si grave en soi ça va ça
pas de l'héroïne non plus c'est pas mais
elle en prendrait tous tellement massive
que ça nous donne juste des nausées des
tremblements de plus en plus de mal à
cacher son entourage à son mari à son
père c'est à tout le monde qu'elle a
besoin de ça pour se lever le matin et
qu'elle a besoin de somnifères pour son
temps mur et que et puis ensuite la pas
tellement envie d'arrêter non plus été
redevenir la gentille petite louise
d'avant qui rougit mois maintenant ça va
et puis c'est la rupture
tu t'attendais à quoi je lui ai dit tu
crois que ça va être facile de me
quitter tu crois que je vais te laisser
faire comme ça j'ai lancé le cadre par
terre le verre s'est brisé
mais comme ce n'était pas assez j'ai
bondi du lit et j'ai déchiré la photo
celle qu'il prétendait tant aimé la
photo de nous deux ans marié beau et
légèrement ridicule
il y avait tant de monde qu'on ne
connaissait pas notre mariage on est
parti avant la fin il ya des supers
phrase d'auteur merci c'est gentil
justin
il faut avoir confiance en lui
emmanuelle seigner en foire concevoir
alors toute la semaine vous attaché de
presse c'est à dire ceux du film et puis
vous attaché de presse personnel m'ont
téléphoné en me disant que vous aviez
peur de devenir dans cette émission ce
soir
pourquoi parce que vous avez peur de
perdre votre mystère en en bien du tout
c'est que vous aimez bien torturé les
gens ah oui mais pas de calais est ce
que ça fait de l'audimat et j'ai pas
envie d'être une de vos victimes
ouais vous avez peur de moi j'ai pas
peur de vous mais j'ai envie de me
servir de vous mais je veux pas que vous
vous serviez de moi cérébrale
on va faire une question votre chat très
très gentil vous préférez quand vous
confondre avec mathilde seigner ou avec
ludivine sagnier
avec personne est-ce que vous avez
préféré être la belle soeur de laurent
gerra ou 2ème et anthony delon non je
réponds pas à ces questions ah bon
pourquoi pas ce que c'est ça m'intéresse
pas ah bon voilà bien la ville qui était
drôle là allez-y banon voulait pas
réparé en malaisie j'écoute
non mais si vous répondez pas je vais
pas vous la posez une va répondre
oui je vous la pose ouais vous êtes à
dire qu'elle est bête après si c'est pas
moi c'est moi de vous torturer la whey
away les rôles se monte à changer à
verser inversée oui non je vais
simplement savoir faisait déjà couché
avec votre mari pour avoir un rôle mais
là je rêve je rêve là vous vous sentez
éminemment supérieur d'un coup non
supérieure de quoi de vous non je trouve
ça vraiment stupide quoi je vais pas
vous évanouir quand même non non
vous avez pas pleurer quand je suis venu
pour défendre le film dans lequel je
suis d'accord bah ça aurait été dommage
effectivement vous veniez pas parce que
vous êtes excellente dans le film c'est
vrai que c'est rare de voir dans un rôle
comme olic qui m'a fait peur j'ai cru
qu'elle est assez rare de voire
excellentes mais là il faut devrait
réparer l'ambiance qui est très dégradée
thierry alors c'est vrai c'est assez
inattendu de quoi de me voir dans un
rôle comique
oui c'est vrai que yvan à une bonne idée
quoi encore cette image
non mais je pense que pour vous c'est un
film aussi important que que place
vendôme parce que j'aurai classement
donc ça vous a révélé un petit peu et ce
fils d'anabaa être à mon avis aussi
important oui je pense mais en même
temps je pense que j'ai j'ai fait du
très bon travail dans frantic ou dans
lunes de fiel mais quand on pense et mis
en scène par roman polanski
les gens et surtout les critiques ne
voit pas ça ils voient pas le travail
ils jugent comme une commune femmes et
pas comme une actrice et donc voila quoi
mais ça va mal
ouais ça va il vous savoir moi ça va
très bien je vous faire une interview
complexe d'actrice oh non
pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi essayons essayons
emmanuelle seigner est ce que vous êtes
et gêné qua non non non non mais je suis
je me dis oui je suis gêné pour emmanuel
parce que je la sens mais je la sens pas
tranquille quoi
même moi ça me crispe ouais moi aussi
remarquer que tous très gris angie vous
êtes crispé et pourtant elle parle pas
français et ne pas te dire une sale
ambiance
c'est commence fort bien ce domaine
[Applaudissements]
toi d'instaurer un climat de sympathie
de convivialité c'est ton travail qui
rit oui j'essaye ah ouais vas-y on a
fait cette interview pas non non vous
les va faire beau oui mais je passe dans
le fond
voulait pas faire pourquoi vous savez
même pas ce que c'est non mais je n'aime
pas trop ces deux crises interview là ça
vous plaît pas ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait
aussi des émissions qui commençait mal
et qui se terminait bien les invités non
mais j'adore il peut y avoir aussi un
renversement de situation vraiment peut
partir sur une super bonne impression
aussi mettons ça dans un coin de notre
tête c'est pas impossible
c'est mal barré mais c'est pas possible
on n'en est pas là
tout joueur je la met là et puis si vous
la sentez en lors de trois ans toute
façon la crise
la touche ne bougera pas on va laisser
ça ici voilà c'est pour vous ouais bon
on passe à angie alors jamais notre
fiche de côté pour alger pascal fera pas
non plus mais là on peut essayer la
première question
ouais les y aller première question je
reviens sur vous tous été après lundi
donc si l'interview complexe d'actrice
emmanuelle seigner est ce que vous êtes
déjà dix actrices
finalement c'est peut-être pas mon truc
oui bah voilà
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit j'ai des
gros mollets non je vous ai déjà dit
j'aime pas mes yeux
non on vous faisait donc s'effacer pas
bien assez complexe d'actrice tanger
tétouan départ le matin chez pour lui
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit mais
qu'est ce qu'il me trouvera mam est ce
que vous êtes déjà dit ma soeur m'a fait
honte
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit je suis
jalouse de charlotte
non est ce que vous êtes déjà dit
j'aimerais quand même faire intervenir
les biens sa table je vous ai déjà dit
j'aimerais qu'on me filme comme ivan
film charlotte
oui c'est bien ça y est ce que vous êtes
déjà dit je n'aurai jamais de ce car
c'est la honte devant mon mari non je
vous ai déjà dit si ce qui ne fait pas
un carton j'arrête le cinéma est ce que
vous êtes déjà dit la critique ne m'aime
pas oui est ce que vous êtes déjà dit
qu'elle compte laurent gerra
alors
facile en entier
[Musique]
non ma fille tu connais leur maman
tiennent aux rebelles j'ai sonné
enfin bernard montiel antisocial
antisociales
bonsoir ça va ça va bouger un peu pop up
leur nom c'est la première fois qu'un
homme me dire anti sociale ça ça m'amuse
beaucoup et oui vous êtes devenu depuis
votre hara kiri en direct dans
l'émission de jean-luc morandini un
antisocial voilà eh oui et tant mieux
d'ailleurs pour vous en morandini vous
demande de choisir entre ardisson et
fogiel
j'ai une question il faut jamais posé
évidemment la vie et aider les familles
entières qui sont discutées pour saha
pendant des générations
depuis l' affaire dreyfus on n'a rien vu
qui divise autant des familles en plein
coeur du centre hygée anéantir des
questions essentielles ça c'est des
questions qui font des guerres civiles
et voilà voilà alors il vous demande de
choisir vous vous oubliez vos esquive
habituel et là on sait pas ce qui vous a
pris
vous répondez franchement et vous dites
art 10 ans est un [ __ ] qui n'arrête
pas de baiser les gens au montage mais
non ce sera coupé ça qu'est ce que tu as
pris avant l'interview c'est ce que tout
le monde se demandait rien
malheureusement
voilà deux groupes crapuleux et bernard
montiel donc balancer et magnanime
ajoute quand même
mais remarquez quand même je trouve
l'émission d'ardisson intéressante c'est
vrai merci bernard
alors est-ce que sérieusement en dehors
de celles ci vous avez des noms de gens
qui sont plaints du montage de cette
émission parce que je suis prêt à aller
à les recevoir pour qu'ils expliquent
mois
laurent gerra il me semble non laurent
gerra il s'est plaint parce que sa
gonzesse est venu dans la même émission
mathilde seigner qu'elle a dit que
c'était un gros beauf
donc cela énervait mais voilà qui
d'autre à brûle pourpoint comme ça je
pense que s'il ya des gens à se plaindre
du montage de cette émission qui
viennent me le dire moi j'ai au
contraire au montage arrange les gens
moi il ya des invités qui participa
choix intelligent vous verrez ça fait
rêver
non mais sérieusement je vais pas faire
la soirée latine mais vous savez quand
même que neuf l'émission sur 10 ans sont
montés drucker mireille dumas
si vous voulez me suis habitué au direct
il avait que moi j'aime le dire un vidéo
gag s'était pas en direct au gac ça vous
n'avez pas vous comparez vidéo quel
geste aussi non non alors je crois que
plus intéressant la télévision c'est
effectivement le direct parce que ça se
passe des choses qui peuvent se passer
des choix du tout d'accord moi oui je
préfère feuilles d'accord parce que je
vais vous dire pourquoi une fois pour
toutes comme ça d'affaires sera clair et
pour nos amis que les spectateurs aussi
quand vous faites une émission en direct
êtes obligés de couper les gens parce
que dans l'oreillette on vous lit fais
gaffe voilà quand vous faites une
émission enregistrée voulait laisser
parler c'est pas toujours la première
fois que vous leur posez la question qui
font la bonne réponse
et puis comme ça on sera plus
intéressant réalisateur de films vous
avez fait des films il diffuse pas le
rush un journaliste de presse écrite qui
vous et qui vous interview il diffuse
pas l'interview tel quel
donc le message c'était pour améliorer
le produit la spontanéité apporter des
choses aussi comme les lire des trucs
voyez ce qui m'est arrivé à la radio
finalement c'est très bien si vous aviez
dit ça dans ses missions j'aurais gardé
au montage je suis là aujourd'hui le
faire chez vous et d'ailleurs oui bon je
sais pas où je vais recommencer alors en
transit sont accrus ciel choisissez qui
larmoient j'aime toujours le direct mes
chers comme j'ai dit je regarde aussi
votre émission qui est très sympathique
c'est qui tu préfères thierry direct la
dernière fois qu'il a répondu à cette
question il était viré de sa chaîne non
quand même remarqué là on peut pas le
virer de nulle part mais si un peu de
grip trois chaînes m
attendez de virton qu'est ce qui t'a
concierge se maintient alors voilà
encore deux ans son aîné et donne rien
mon frère bien alors ensuite donc vous
enchaînez je raconte votre livre là un
bernard vous enchaînez les vidéos gags
vous dites c'est alimentaire c'est pas
compliqué je pose mon gros cul ça c'est
une phrase à moi où l'avait piqué crocus
et moi je pose mon gros cul sur la
banquette et je touche un paquet oui
j'avais déjà dit chez vous et le
producteur de vidéo gag m'a appelé en me
disant que c'est pas trop aimer ce que
tu as dit j'ai dit c'est pas grave tout
on était resté là quoi alors vous
continuez vous le parler de l'émission
de 2 jean pierre foucault vous dites
zone rouge c'est une vraie connerie qui
m'a alors parlé d' arthur aussi vous dit
même avec un prompteur
c'est vrai qu'en ces deux autres simples
puisse rire tout à coup on retrouve sa
mère on est joyeux on est frétille ont
dit qu'ils allaient me sauvadet donc il
dit bernard mon ami bernard dit arthur
même avec un prompteur il se plante
c'est un nul
julien courbet très drôle aussi ce que
vous dites c'est la grosse tête il se
prend pour le zorro de la télé love
story députés des gigolos plaît c'est un
peu moins bien encore pire car 10
android seraient pas qui veut du bien
et alors alors là on en arrive à bernard
tapie et c'est là c'est grave et dit
c'est un escroc mal mais je suis un
escroc qui présentait une émission naze
vous savez quand même sérieusement pas
vous donner le sens de marc bernard
tapie il a été condamné il a purgé sa
peine et aujourd'hui il est plus un
escroc il a oui mais vous avez dit le
reste de cette phrase l'aurait j'ai dit
bon il a purgé sa peine effectivement il
faut plus l'emmerdé avec ça ouais c'est
moi le seul problème si vous voulez
c'est que on avait un petit contentieux
avec monsieur tapie que j'ai évoquées
dans le bouquin et voilà et que
mission était naze ailleurs à cet arrêté
c'est pas de ma faute c'est de la sienne
que vous ayez bon comédien je reconnais
mais qu'elle a été condamnée pour
escroquerie donc c'est une invention
d'autant plus que dans les couloirs de
tf1
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle dans
l'escroc ouais alors qu'ils se
débrouillent avec les gens de tf1 puis
j'ai ça aussi pour vous
alors là vous savez que vous avez fait
la gaffe la grosse gaffe
alors le gros souci en perspective
vous vous dites et le lendemain dans le
parisien il ya un papier
alors vous avez un réflexe disons assez
attendu finalement vous appelez tapis
pour vous excuser un maintenant je
voulais lui parler pour qu'ils sachent
bien exact parce qu'évidemment dans la
presse sortie juste les petites phrases
assassines
je voulais vraiment lui dire jusqu'au
bout non qui scellèrent pas pour rien et
je sais que quand j'ai appelé dans son
bureau j'ai hurlé derrière déjà et m'a
jamais parlé très sympa pour m'excuser
c'était pour en parler pas possible de
lui parler
non moi vous n'avez pas cherché en jaune
pour vous excuser noms avancés pour ça
que m'est pas appelé ouais c'est pas
très grave c'est pas parce que je compte
- une mère un tapis non un accord aussi
je suis des émissions bien et alors
finalement en fait ce que vous dites
dans votre bouquin c'est que vous avez
été viré de tf1 puisque mougeotte est
pas tellement énervé mais à cause de
l'insistance de bernard tapie qui dit
vous êtes un ami de patrick le lay oui
et vous sous-entendez que tapie aurait
des moyens de pression sur le lait jarry
vous a parlé qui vous a parlé
il nous a parlé
et vous a parlé en parlant de 10 mois
tf1 s'ils me font chier je sors la boîte
à gifles
c'est ce qu'il dit dans tous les dîners
alors finalement vous êtes viré de tf1
remplacé par un nommé sébastien folin et
qui dit vous parce que lui tout de suite
il prend la relève le makhila il arrive
à sa place il faut balancer il balance
il dit oui mondiale il est malheureux il
est oui je l'espère saab avant sa mort
j'espère que 45 ans je ne serai pas
comme ça a dit sébastien voilà c'est
drôle s'envolent les écrits restent donc
je n'avais toujours là c'est terrible la
télé quand même mais c'est le fola c'est
la mode flash il vous banal et ma paye
s'est excusé il s'est excusé ce qui est
bien la télé c'est que les mecs ses
excuses en disant j'ai pas vraiment dit
ça c'est l'extraordinaire ont été une
taxe sur les excuses au porteur je peux
vous dire que la france reste le
tiers-monde mangerait mieux même si cela
votre chien était viala aussi forcément
elle a été piquée par tfc chien en
direct parce qu'il adore le direct
bernard dans celui là j'en viens un côté
beaucoup plus positif
vous racontez votre enfance et je dois
dire que c'est assez touchant à me
raconter votre enfance de deux jeunes
petits pieds noirs fils de cheminot qui
a du mal à s'intégrer
moi je ne suis pas pieds noirs mais j'ai
vu l'arrivée des pieds noirs en 62 à
salon de provence
je vois comment ils ont été reçus par
les métros et je suis assez sensible à
ça votre famille a quitté casablanca en
1961 vos premiers souvenirs c'est votre
mère qui pleure évidemment et quand vous
arrivez donc on dit tiens voilà les
arabes en phase avec les métros ont
accueilli les pieds noirs d'une façon
assez d assez déplorable et vous êtes
obligés d'enlever vos chaussettes dans
la cour de l'école pour montrer que vos
pieds ne sont pas noirs on se rend on se
rend pas compte dans le racisme violent
qui a accueilli les pieds noirs ont
paroisse en rouge sang sur les murs de
votre maison votre maison est caillassée
pendant la nuit fait voilà vous êtes
très humilié quand vous êtes petit et
ceci explique sans doute votre désir
d'intégration
ensuite vous arrivez à paris évidemment
vous avez de la chance tout de suite
c'est la télé la jet set mais vous vous
êtes suffisamment police et pour
intégrer cette société parisienne pour
ensuite ne plus ouvrir votre gueule je
dirais pendant de longues années c'est
ça l'histoire
vous avez l'air de bien le comprendre
nous sommes là je le comprends parce que
je les ai vus c'est à dire foulée votre
vraie nature
pour être accepté par les autres en fait
c'est ça votre problème c'est vrai ça a
mis longtemps à exploser ouais et à 46
ans vous imaginez il ya là ils font
jamais remarqué chez vous et fermez
votre gueule pendant 17 ans vous savez
que vous étiez mépriser un petit peu par
les mépriser à la fois c'est les gens ne
se rendent pas compte on fait un métier
populaire bon l'émission l'été ce qu
elle était gelée très bien assumé
pendant un nombre d'années suffisant
mais c'est vrai que vidéo gag c'était
vidéo gagne l'émission légère
divertissement suppose en voyant ce mec
sourire ça va être un gros con forcément
ou alors vraiment si là que ça dans sa
vie donc à force ça dans le quotidien
c'est pénible c'est dur à vivre
alors les amis qui vous connaissent
mieux vous dise mais fait autre chose
couleur tu t'intéresses tu lis des
bouquins tout le temps tu t'intéresses à
l'art sous toutes ses formes fait autre
chose et je me suis plus là dedans je le
reconnais que c'est pourquoi bernard ne
pas avoir démissionné à l'époque c'est
ça pour pourquoi avoir attendu cette
espèce de rebellions par inadvertance
chez morandini un matin sur europe 1
pourquoi pas avoir démissionné de tf1
parce que j'ai pas eu le courage
franchement c'est pour ça je m'en suis
voulu et que je suis allé au fond du
trou parce que tout ça était de ma faute
c'est moi qui suis rentré dans cette
merde quelque part et qui était très
confortable jeu là vous et cette
faiblesse de ma part mme
vraiment me hanter quoi il fallait je
fasse quelque chose les humains mon
garçon oui tout ce qui est plus émouvant
c'est ça c'est cette faiblesse de dire
oui j'ai battu et voilà ouais et je
trouve ça très beau alors qu'il ya quand
même un truc un honnêtement moi je
comprends assez bien tout ça je veux
dire le petit de petits pieds noirs qui
se fend merde je vois très bien le truc
et franchement j'ai de la compassion
pour votre histoire
simplement il ya comme un truc dont vous
avez été complice et vous le racontez
assez franchement dans votre bouquin
c'est vers le chapitre 25
c'est chantal nos mails ah oui sur tel
domaine c'est grave parce que là vous
êtes complice d'un truc sur ces sabatier
qui doit faire des missions finalement
il l'a fait pas c'est vous qui la fête
est là vous fait croire au public que
chantal nobel est parfaitement rétabli
ce qui n'est pas le cas vous le savez
tout le monde le sait et il faut faire
croire qu'elle est rétabli mais non plus
pas trop parce qu'il faut pas mettre en
péril ses négociations avec les avait
avec les assurances
il ya beaucoup d'argent en jeu vous
savez que les questions et réponses sont
écrites à l'avancé par william abitbol
vous le dites dans votre bouquin qui
devenu ensuite un conseil de charles
pasqua et et vous savez que l'interview
est enregistrée question par question et
que ses tournées comme du cinéma alors
affreux vous êtes prêté à saverne ou
complètement
c'était le c'était au début c'était au
début de ma carrière à tf1 est très vite
évidemment il en a disons en enlever
sabatier qui était la star du moment et
qui lui risque est de faire de l'ombre
un peu à cette émission
quant à nos belles c'était la star donc
oui le petit jeune et puis mis très vite
la manipulation était tellement énorme
cette pauvre chantal nobel bon qui
heureusement maintenant va bien est
rétablie tant mieux pour elle mais à
l'époque un ne comprenait strictement
rien eu à faire et imprimés mémoire
d'ailleurs de faux souvenirs
le faux souvenirs ça c'est grave et elle
n'arrivait même pas à lire le prompteur
la peau c'était je posais la même
question au foie imaginer de répéter on
se voit là même qui voit là et c'est
pour ça excusez moi de vous le dire et
puis ce sera la dernière fois il parlera
quand vous venez me donner des leçons de
morale sur le montage au plus tôt
honnêtement
il est bien trop serré serré à la
différence
moi j'étais pas projecteurs cette
émission garnett producteurs d'accord
écoutez nous bien maman tient on a
vraiment envie de vous aider ou la balle
en plein air a dit non mais pourquoi
vous voyez le mal parti on a vraiment
envie de vous aider et on va faire une
interview sauvons dernièrement thiel
vous allez voir c'est très simple c'est
très sain bernard on va vous demander de
dire des trucs gentils sur les gens et
comme ça vous avez un petit creux lis
des choses gentilles mais sur arthur par
exemple il a une très belle femme à
l'homme c'est bien non sur jean pierre
foucault je crois que c'est un vrai
gentil
ouais ça fait avancer c'est un vrai
gentil cultiver bien cultiver oui ça va
lui faire dire à trop quand même
emad il est vraiment gentil et
gentillesse sur courbet on vous aide là
on fait ça pour vous ça c'est très dur
une sortie je sais il est drôle en
société il est drôle en société bernard
tapie ah oui c'est dur je sais mais
c'est pour vous qu'on fait c'est un bon
comédien
un bon comédien bien thierry ardisson
cela knitter iv a du coeur c'est bien
etienne mougeotte lui était plutôt
d'accord avec moi donc lui même il était
d'accord avec ce que j'ai dit certaines
personnes n'ont pas besoin de dire du
bien donc bataille et fontaine c'est dur
je sais et m'ont proposé de rentrer sur
tf a rigolé rivedoux jamais dire
fontaine et ça c'était ce que vient
réchauffer six mois pour bénéficier
toujours que yann mot fothen dans une
phrase un débat times jamais il est
arrivé les choses de bien quand il ya le
mot fourtet jamais qui vous ouvrirez
nidowien régional wallon brenner casas
idée d'une fontaine rien et je venais ou
qu'une chose qui se passe bien cela nous
ôter
au désespoir et danube j'ai mûri près de
la porte et les belles soldats
surréaliste et gagné exactement carole
rousseau là c'est impossible je sais ce
que je nomme alors là je m'en vais là je
sais lui dit on lui dit on veut te
sauver dit du bien de carole rousseau il
a le type envie de se sauver mais j'y
arrivais pas bernard c'est plus fort que
vous c'est au dessus de vos forces
larusso bon elle n'existe pas façon
obama mama mama mama
[Applaudissements]
certainement
mourier
je suis dit que je m'habille elle fut
romantique parfait mais c'est en
regardant regarde oui alors bon soir
c'est le grand retour de jean draps il
devra vous vous souvenez c'était ça
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
à
bien
les amis
ouais c'est fini
le président vient le tube d'avant et
puis voilà ça fait quatre ans qu'on vous
a pas vu à temps et demi parce que moi
je compte les mois et les jours oui
indra c'est trop long ouais ça fait
longtemps qu'on sait pas jouer indra bah
oui alors en 2000 vous êtes mariés en
suisse un fait j'ai un petit garçon qui
s'appelle only qu'à bientôt stanko voilà
et vous avez abandonné votre carrière
artistique vous occuper du petit oui et
nous ne pouvons que vous en suisse il
était jolie jackson quand le petit oliba
bien il va très bien il l'est d'ailleurs
roulis et voilà maintenant la voilà au
lille et toulouse c'était bien cette
expérience de maman
absolument j'ai c'est le première fois
donc premier bébé c'est pas évident ça
s'est très très bien passé même
l'accouchement péridurale cependant dit
moi je trouve ça a été avec 10 min à
thomson de ça
je dis peut-être faire parce que je
trouve qu'il n'a pas cette femme en
france qui calait de ses enfants parce
qu'à l'heure c'est la grande mode en
appela ses lamas les plus en plus et ont
besoin et c'est très bien pour les
enfants
moi j'achète du lait devant un aussi bel
emballage ensuite connu séparée du papa
des très bons amis je fais beaucoup on
sépare de ses fils à la main c'est comme
un art il paraît oui donc la musique
avec le papa donc voilà et vous revenez
à paris vous revoyez orlando avec qui le
contact n'était pas du tout rompu en
finlande où vous invite au concert
d'hélène ségara parce que ces deux gars
comme quoi c'est celle ci ont plein
voilà
et donc est donc au concert d'hélène
ségara là où il ya les rencontres avec
les gouverneurs rencontrer
professionnels vous avez vous avez
déclaré d'abord qu'ils étaient très
mignons et orlando n'est pas mal non
plus mais alors c'est chiant honnêtement
les chefs d' orlando c'est du renard
c'est vrai de loisirs
lui c'est un renard si c'est lui qui a
écrit le dossier de presse orlando là
j'ai des trucs qui vont pas dans le
dossier de presse 1 il ya des trucs sur
les choses depuis longtemps qu'ils sont
un peu ça change parce qu'on ne pourrait
pas en profiter pour remettre les choses
d'aplomb votre âge par exemple je suis
né 67 donc c'est facile à faire le
calcul
donc c'est pas 35 j'avais 38
c'est pas grave même qu'un l'âge de 13
ans il faut aussi aussi moi j'étais je
faisais du défilé l'adolescente à l'âge
de 13 ans c'est vrai il ya une phrase
que que j'adore de vous inra bonjour le
showbiz est un milieu extraordinaire
je n'ai jamais ressenti quelque chose de
malsain c'est vrai ou peut-être un côté
innocente qui fait que je ne sais pas si
c'est ce que tu es innocent non neige et
commence à voir parce que peut-être avec
l'âge la main gauche en écharpe
ok à dire la poche de la trentaine à
l'inra en 95 quand vous attaquez
penthouse parce qu'ils diffusent des
photos de vous à pois c'est quand même
non non je pense vraiment que cela mais
ça y avait un photographe elle était à
poil c'est dur on a fait des photos pour
marx magazine nuls aux pouilles à
l'époque donc il avait beaucoup de
mannequins d'ailleurs qui se mettaient
un peu nîmes pas pas des choses pour
nous et puis on a trouvé que le résultat
n'était pas ça donc la maison disent
qu'elle avait racheté tous ces photos
lui le photographe il avait fait des
duplicatas et quatre ans après il a
ressorti les photos donc c'est pour ça
qu'on attaque et voilà mais c'est pas
mal ça a été chaud mais c'était surtout
mal ça c'est qu'il est aussi des photos
qui sont qui ont été sortis dans des
journaux en suède et mes parents quand
même un peu c'était pas très drôle mais
il ya plus grave plus grave c'est grave
quoi kerry et maintenant on passe au
musée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est moi rennais l'as monaco sera pas
mon ami nocera l'on dévoile elle est là
donne ton avis
alors
c'est là
c'est vrai
mais maria
bravo
k
le temps d'y faire
vous n'êtes pas vu depuis quand même
sens tous les deux la jeunesse selon
lesquelles que les parce qu'il craignait
sommes trompés
67 ans c'est un événement alors qu'ils
en 20 ans c'est tentant de vous
retrouver par de l'anxiété chez roxy est
à versailles à l'aise pour voir mes
classes et l'inde - oui mais à plusieurs
reprises aussi parce que je m'y
attendais pas je savais la forêt dans le
dynamisme
bellemare a oui vous êtes plus parler au
téléphone j'ai pu écrit avoir classé lui
remettre trouve être dur quand la page
est tournée
un chardonneret les tournées mais le
bouquin et là ça vous a manqué qui vous
qui nous appellent pas
on peut tout dire à cette heure là je
suis un peu surprise c'est pas très bon
mais qu'est ce qu'on dit quand on se
voit comme ça on parle quoi du danemark
je pense pas on n'a jamais dit claude
allard mais deux fois manqué au danemark
on se dit quoi oui sa vie une fois que
j'avais quitté ma mère c'était c'était
jean luc mon mari c'était aussi un peu
mon père mon frère et puisqu'il s'est
terminée à cause des primes et
détournement de mineure non non non pas
des temps je dirais pas qu'ils
consentent tournage tournant tournage
terminé alors comme épouse a été
commandé cet avion n'avaient l'homme
alors je fais pas maintenant je veux
être de faire tourner quelques uns et le
soir de se retrouver à la maison
ensemble ça que je vous dire bah il
voyageait beaucoup j'en ai qu avant ils
étaient très tournés tout le temps ouais
il était tout le temps c'est aussi une
association comme ça je pense pas qu'on
ait vraiment lieu
en fait je faisais jamais marché du
recul ce qui va dans ses films mais
c'est une erreur mais une erreur
séduisant qu'il est probablement vu ça
de ma femme avait peut-être trop jeune
le cinéma commence qu'à 30 ans je
t'aimerai finalement pensé qu'il fallait
mais parce que j'avais lu compenser le
manque d'amour
en ce qu'il faut avoir un grand amour
n'en est pas capable les femmes
pouvaient favoriser ce que j'avais
d'abord où l on souffre certainement et
moi tout ce que je pouvais donner c'est
des films mais le moment un film on sait
rien et ce à cause de ça vous êtes
quitter finalement c'est parce que vous
n'aviez pas assez à lui donner
traitement et puis je crois que j'avais
aussi moi je copiais donc je voulais
faire je me dirais moi après tout il y
avait en ce noël c'est john baird
marlene dietrich renoir et catherine s
line
lorsque j'ai moi aussi donc c'est un
modèle eh bien on voit que la très bon
ce modèle permet de faire certains films
et puis que les films après ont du mal à
repasser dans dans la vie et que ça
jamais bien bien marché est-ce complète
aussi heureux après parce que c'est que
ce grand amour ont concerné différemment
s'atténue non mais je comprends moi je
pense qu'on peut l'être alors beaucoup
plus
ouais c'est que demain et toujours
[Musique]
les blessés
pas moins
je deviens d'homme d'état donc on peut
pas moi je pleure pas chez moi
pas en maillot sur la plage horaire 10
ah bon tu devrais pas moins à taper sur
la cage récents la plage puisque je me
suis pas blessé mais toutes les toutes
les grandes stars s'appellent tous ses
biens elle s'est même pas les grands du
sahara en général
tu sais pas si vous avez grandes stars
se dépannaient étude est une quand c'est
les brûler les plus sexy sans pas les
meilleurs chevaux
c'est bien connu ça à mes filles compte
ou à l'extérieur on n'avait rien
j'ai à faire flipper hamadi meilleur
coup ses brasseries du tout l'air de
rien que je dis mais quand y c'est un
super poubelle si moi j'ai pas faire de
la basse et a fini moi je suis un mec
j'ai tranché encore jamais tu va
décevoir monte à 2 jours en fait quand
même
tu dis c'est pas les sexy les meilleurs
coups n'était quand même pas mauvais
coups rassure moi qu'on peut lui
demander il sera passé 1
des costauds en fait une victoire
planchet panier du match mc du régent en
allemand
qui garde très bien contemporaine était
très bien
ils ont tous fait là
tu as raison c'est la vérité mais
j'étais quand même cassé de chez toi à
15 ans mais je n'étais pas fâché contre
mes parents tout le monde à 15 ans et
demi c'est parce qu'elle est et ce que
ses parents il a eu des problèmes comme
tout moment donc je vais réfléchir c'est
sûr mais il était tout à fait d'accord
il était tellement la ville on habitait
ensemble qui sont dit tu tires tu as
raison tu as raison
mais au début quand tu étais à paris
avait 15 ans et demi quand elle vient du
coucher avec toi mais quand même
je suis arrivé avec un mec est ce assez
mais ce n'est pas déjà quand marie
m
quand on a eu deux vagues de la hauteur
je te dirai pas j'étais sur un tel
problème de ma mère je crois
et jamais un producteur
non mais c'est pas parce que
tonn et hans qui n'ont pas plu ouais
m'enfin faut coucher avec un producteur
si les votes
je me dire mais je serai prêt à vendre
dans l'instant il n'y a aucun producteur
en garde
il m'a plu
tu parles toujours pensé miles
jean bédard bien qu'il y avait ce qu'il
fallait
en parler d'une femme a pas moins de 400
et marées elle est styliste
c'est vrai qu'un jour dans une fête
foraine a gagné 48 passes en rouge à la
série lost est petit à la kermesse de
mon école mais c'est toujours une chance
de bien suivre
c'est ma mère qui faisait la gueule mais
ouais c'est une chance pas possible
entendu une fois que je vais pas ton
visage à l'écran qui trouvait un peu
d'art auront
un peu répugne aux noms bizarres non je
dirais même pas à l'idée du visage
repasser mais le mien comme le tien je
n'aime pas l'idée d'être dans une petite
boîte doit ressembler nikon
électroménagère d'avoir d'être sur 50 et
62 d'avoir des gestes relativement de
policiers d'avoir une cravate ou même
une chemise lacoste pour ça devient
presque un symbole
j'aime pas l'idée d'être assimilée à une
étiquette anti ardisson sénoufo fois
c'est le soft machin truc ça je ne sais
même pas où on est on est si peu ça on
est un petit bout de ça on est un petit
poêle détails vers les salariés ont fait
vivre beaucoup réduit beaucoup oui parce
que là on raconte on raconte sa vraie
vie on raconte ses fantasmes ses envies
enfin son envie de sortir de sa grande
peur de vieillir
non non pas encore mais je n'aime pas du
tout
ça j'en parle dans mon effet l'idée de
l'idée de la compromission c'est à dire
je pense est assez stupidement et
peut-être aussi stupidement plage à
l'âge de 15 ans je pensais que c'était à
40 ans qu'on commençait justement à
tomber aller de l'autre côté de la pente
et avoir des petits poils de moisissures
de choses donc on accepte qu'il fait des
choses qui me plaisent pas comme ça j'ai
l'impression de relativement bien tenir
ma vie pour l'instant mais je me méfie
quand même message ils devraient faire
d'être chaud par exemple
intérim en jeu de foot je n'aime pas ma
tête je parle avec les filles depuis
pouvoir bandes est ou n'est plus comme
ça j'ai horreur de genre de questions
encore plus des gens ne râlent france
pourquoi parce que ça te ressemble si
peu moi qui connais ça je sais que c'est
uniquement une question pour pour faire
plaisir et pour justifier une revue
d'assaut au fait des livres de maisons
solides
vous êtes tentant de problèmes de faits
divers dans sa bouche elle le paquet
paparazzi des célébrités dont vous avez
été quand même en ce moment
l'urbanisation du plaisir en lui même je
crois
à
ah oui c'est vrai donc j'ai moi je fais
plus blasés que vous parce que j'ai eu
ça l'histoire des drogues douces à en 81
à 86 et la maintenance et un petit
bâtiment et comme ils descendent tout ça
va rapper bête dans la mesure où c'est
une question de par rapport à moi je
suis fais ce que je crois que parce
qu'il faisait dans la constitution des
droits de l'homme il ya des bruits fait
ce qu'il veut devancer liberté ne trace
pas celle d'autres illustres ceux ci ont
prévu d exemple je trouve ça dix trucs
très dangereux parce que les
scientifiques privés qu'il ya 1000 km
libre il a quelques raisons gens jeunes
qui peuvent s'imaginer qu'on est oui
grâce à la copine d'un sex-symbol
exemple sagan et fait des bons livres
c'est finalement william chris brown se
disperse explique le coach ont donc une
nouvelle idée d en parler et puis on m'a
tout simplement comme une des fois où
les gens qui sont inconnus qui peuvent
se réjouir d'être honteux lettre ne
pourrait la police a droit de violer
cette instruction à la police de le
faire je voyais que soient ses
interviews il faut pas le faire soit
c'est autorisé faut que ça se fasse
qu'on a assuré mathieu paradis il faut
dire ça aux acquis de droit je suis nous
regarde
[Musique]
sinon leur enverra une cassette nous
vous pensez que c'est pour des raisons
politiques que votre camp et étudié dans
cette affaire moi je pense pas toujours
à défaut si si si sérieuse le cas
échéant donnés le samedi bêtement j'ai
chaque fois avant les élections effet
que des puits tjp séparés depuis nos
politiques je préviens
rien répond quand même
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu disais que tu aimais bien le singe
parce qu'il y avait quatre mains ses
contours lit des trucs comme ça dans le
journal c'est vachement séparent mais ça
me choque ce genre d'entraîneur passe
quand on vous pose la question pourquoi
aimez-vous les singes c'est vrai que
c'est difficile ça paraît tellement
évident c'est vrai que non seulement il
à quatre mains c'est à dire qu'il peut
vraiment
tripoter tous les objets reproduire tout
ce que vous pouvez écrire lire enfin
c'est assez étonnant
mais ce n'est pas que ça c'est un singe
c'est fascinant parce que c'est vraiment
terriblement proche de l'orne
mes amis mes sept mois sauf qu'il ya
quatre ans tu pouvais faire vivre avec
un sage qu'avec un homme tu n'es pas
avec anna bligh
tu vis tout ça les concerne ne verrait
pas pourquoi parce que ça c'est quelque
chose que je présenterai un bon je suis
très tu t'es très attention à ta bille à
sa vie privée
j'ai très attention à ton image
finalement je sais pas si c'est faire
très attention je crois que je n'ai
aucun plaisir
à parler de ça voilà c'est quoi ton
plaisir mon plaisir c'est de chanter
c'est le cinéma c'est la musique c'est
du son à la peinture
je ne sais pas j'aime aller au cinéma
dans les médias pourquoi pas à signer
moi je ne sais pas mais reste de ta vie
c'est quoi un partenariat avec moi à
part me marier avec vous je sais pas si
c'est le rêve de ma vie mais j'ai très
très très envie un jour de d'élever des
singes avant emerson souare this way moi
j'ai vu un jour un reportage sur diane
fossey sur saignement qui vivait au
kenya les chez moi et c'était formidable
là c'est une femme qui m'a donné envie
d'élever des 108 envie d'avoir plein de
petits sachets torres
il se maria et sur place ou déroutants
ou d'ego rire si j'adopte et des singes
suite marierait avec moi j'y ai réfléchi
merci
aubin sauges sd
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'est
bien alors donc le dj dublin ps ce soir
c'est leur envol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir l'ansa vous connaissez le
principe du brent est d'abord celle e
par équipe
hélas dit laurent ruquier c'est donc
laurent ruquier contre laurent baffie ce
soir mais de laurent préférés vont
s'affronter ce soir dans un combat à
mort et vous connaissez le principe je
veux l'interprète 1
indra you know that bébés compris tu
veux qu'elle n'est pas blonde on y va
laurent
[Musique]
jeudi
ouais à l'effort et à vue il a reconnu à
la première est extraordinaire c'est pas
si on continue laurent wolf
le soleil
on sait ni
bon ben ça fait deux points pour
l'équipe de laurent ruquier bravo
laurent bravo jean bravo madame
on passe au troisième non non c'est
milla debout non de souffler ici alors
en valeur
vous devriez savoir depuis le temps
quand je faisais ici le point bas est
[Musique]
bien
ouais
[Musique]
allez
et là ça devient un tout petit peu plus
compliqué laurent
gilbert unique et la ligue arabe qui dit
david a en premier pascal
[Applaudissements]
sinon qu'est ce tu fous de brantes la
fosse rattraper un petit peu à la
tutelle branlée comme en asie comme en
asie
oui donc qu'on continue qu'à châteauroux
allez
[Musique]
c'est bon
5 0
il a répété tous les titres mais pas du
tout il a rien et bd du tout y est le
oakley on continue non j'ai le pouvoir
le comité
[Applaudissements]
hélas
au volant on continue laurent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or là
il
à
m
5 2 on continue les idoles
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
janina et je suis ici
[Applaudissements]
c'est carcassonne édition qui ressemble
au sprint cologna n'a pas d'autre à
paris les parpaings à ça mérite un point
la raison
[Applaudissements]
m
leblanc
mais je suis quand même que mon truc en
plumes été trouvé par laurent et moi
bizarrement magloire major magot et si
tu veux marquer un point tu peux le
gagner
maintenant tu as vu en levant les poings
man show business tu crois dire
[Applaudissements]
il
oui
alors non mais où là pascal at war
comment alors qu'elle atteint il demande
à la raison deux points pour ma gloire
parce qu'un baiser
[Applaudissements]
attends je vous demande de vous arrêter
non c'était très bien dans cette
émission 20 ans toute personne membre à
sang sur la bouche aura deux points
plusieurs les hommes c'est la bruche a
fait
à
m
elle a mis la langue ça fait 4 points
[Applaudissements]
danilo way
et
et ici je mène 4-3 est ce que c'est
délicat parce que franchement non la
série parce que le blitz qui était un
truc un peu dean cette émission s'est
vendu 7 show business c'est comme le
spectacle de la société seulement voilà
on continue laurent garde ton calme
alors
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
m
sarenza tardé à donner les enfants nés
sur le service public on est on est sur
le service public cinq points voilà
douze bambou
[Applaudissements]
je lui
mais quand
le roc au blind test au banc de test
event
franchement ça fait trop chaud sinon tu
veux gagner six points série a doit sait
combien ces mules guerre j'ai rien d
après toi tu te défonces pour l'asie si
facile mais des fonds soient sûres
voilà on continue laurent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel il va falloir y aller gagner
avec abba oui oui oui à six points de la
hongrie et en suède alors oui bien sûr
six points ça s'appelle de profiter de
son travail pour faire des ouattaristes
abus de biens sociaux web asie lors
entamé
ça touche
[Applaudissements]
lartigue série gars et bigard qui
embrasse le mieux de tout ce que j'ai en
europe mardeuil la hat embrasse bien
marquer d'un thème à l'échelle alouettes
jean marie laborde jean marc regard pour
un baiser sur la teneur de ma femme
anelka d'air ouais on est dans
l'émission c'est ce qui me font là pour
gagner pour gagner des points il
m'embrassait toute personne membre à
sang sur la bouche à quatre points avec
la langue c'est 10 points le banco banco
fait bercy en train d'imiter ce que tu
imagines voilà ouais je sais je crois
que c'était ma femme ça me rassure que
ce soit toi bon je t'embrasse caméra
tout à l'heure tu y as ouf c'est pas ma
femme on continue laurent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
continu-continu continue inexorablement
laurent
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui
oh
mon continue -
ouais
oh
[Musique]
m
et voilà à la fin du par équipes
l'équipe de laurent quitte à 12 points
non ça peut s'arranger
et l'équipe de l'as rome 8e 22 points un
peu de stratégie on va leur a valu une
peine pour le super banco après ce qu'on
a vécu avant franchement c'est le cas de
le dire oui il ya des moments où il faut
coucher puis c'est tout voilà depuis ses
15 ans qui se dit maintenant j'aime
beaucoup plus audacieuse qu'avant
maintenant c'est la fin d'une part et de
kinshasa 69 on passe au bon qu voilà
premier banc colorants
la télé
[Musique]
m
laurent
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
attention le méga banques or là c'est
très dur
alors là si vous trouvez ça m'a dit non
[Applaudissements]
non non
[Musique]
on
non
ma fille remporte le méga bon coup avec
un plat qui paie commande arc ça
franchement on a déjà eu un plaisir il
s'est tellement d'enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]